Ja da bin ich jetzt doch das glatt hier mein mikrofon ausgegangen hallo hier ist die freakshow endlich endlich,
zweihundertachtundvierzig wir werden die zwar fünfzigste sendung niemals erreichen das ist euch klar oder die welt stemmt sich dagegen.
Du bist risikogruppe.
Wir sind alle jetzt die risikogruppe mein freund.
Taler und ich möchte euch da bitte auf aufgeschlossen wissen.
Nix da seid alle betroffen.
Erstens mädchen zweitens noch weit unter fünfzig.
Betroffen ja keine risikogruppe.
Und huckel auch.
Das sind da sind jetzt auch schon sechzehnjährige mädchen verstorben also ich bitte dich so.
Richtig es gibt auch schlimme vergleiche in dem unteren hälfte der gesellschaft aber.
Aber nicht in der mitte will sie damit sagen.
Gerade selber als untere hälfte der gesellschaft.
Na wenn ich irgendwie anders formuliert sind die ganzen alten herren wieder beleidigt.
Vorteil nochmal geklärt haben.
Okay lass uns erstmal hier statusmeldungen machen also wir ist die freakshow und ich fühlte mich jetzt leider gezwungen durch den bösen corona das zu machen was ich eigentlich immer vermeiden wollte nämlich die komplette freakshow remote zu machen aber offensichtlich
geht es ja nicht anders also soll es nun mal so sein und jetzt sitzen wir da genauso wie alle anderen auch die
diesen planeten starren auf dem bildschirm um uns irgendwie aus der ferne zuzuwinken nein ihr ihr kriegt keinen videostream von uns
soweit sind wir dann noch nicht.
Werden ja dann auch sieben videos streams wäre dann schon wieder ein bisschen zu viel.
Na ja gut ich meine wenn man es mal professionell machen will dann schick mir ja dann einen mix raus ne,
aber ist ja nicht professionell hier ist ja nur metaebene und von daher gibt es halt einen schönen audio feed und alle sind dabei ich stelle mal vor clemens ist da aus seinem land schloss,
sieht auch so aus bei dir genau,
wieder ein mythos dahin.
Das ist ja nur das leben gelassen hier im hauptgang finden gerade andere dinge statt.
Neben gelassen okay das ist also clemens aus dem leben gelassen tala hallo tala,
moin auch aus dem heim genau wir tot menschen an der wand rotti unser corona king,
trägst du da auch gerade corona bier.
Nein franziskaner alkoholfrei.
Hallo,
so so und ja wer mein seitenkante mal u k w schon mal reingehört hat da haben wir über dein elend gesprochen du hast ja wahrscheinlich den eulen virus eingefangen aber du gehörst zu denen die,
unter wie heißt es so schön milde symptome laufen also bis jetzt sozusagen auf einem level mit boris johnson.
Wenn das milde symptome sind dann will ich die nicht milden gar nicht wissen also ganz ehrlich.
Die will man nicht haben.
Wie wie geht es dir jetzt gerade so also was dein status.
Ach ja schon ganz gut ich war gestern das erste mal seit zweieinhalb wochen draußen habe mir gleich einkaufen beim supermarkt gegeben war ein erlebnis.
Toilettenpapier bekommen.
Aber ich habe auch noch also ich weiß nicht was was was für eine darmtätigkeit andere leute haben aber bei mir reicht das was ich vor ungefähr acht wochen gekauft habe immer noch also es ist irgendwie ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe da wirklich die merkwürdigen einschätzungen gehört auch leute die der meinung sind sie bräuchten irgendwie hundertzwanzig blatt pro woche ist ich habe mich dann auch ein bisschen gefragt was die eigentlich so machen.
Sie missbrauchen als küchencrew.
Ja das sind auch glaube ich diskussionen die man da nicht unbedingt weiterführen sollte also nicht nicht ohne weiteres zumindest machen wir erstmal vorstellungsrunde fertig letti ist auch dabei hallo letti.
Hallo.
Bei mir in der mitte des bildschirms.
Bei uns allen in der mitte des bildschirms vielleicht das richtig sehe oder wir sind.
Also in der mitte ist bei mir rudi das.
Ach so ich dachte wir werden dann auch alle an der.
Taler in der mitte.
Kann man das reh arrangieren ja irgendwie falls ihr euch fragt wir benutzen natürlich wie alle gerade jessi und ich muss auch sagen es funktioniert besser als ich dachte aber dann sprechen wir nachher drüber erstmal fertig vorstellen da haben wir noch hockey,
guten abend okay huckel ist da,
und der vogel ganz unten mit toilettenpapier genau und meine eine tim hallo herzlich willkommen zurück in der freakshow und jetzt gucken wir mal wie das so funktioniert ja.
Dezentral.
Macht kannst du den eindruck ne.
Mehr so ein meter raum.
Genau metaebene braucht halt immer ne also man muss die dinge immer eliminieren können auf die nächste ebene und da biete ich mich dann eigentlich permanent an so läuft das halt.
Bist du ein bisschen traurig dass du alleine in der metaebene sitzt.
Es geht so weil es ist immer noch extrem.
Jetzt nicht sagen.
Es ist es ist total unaufgeräumt und ich schäme mich ja schon seit längerem dass ich dieses chaos hier nicht im griff kriege und gerade als ich drauf und dran war das alles besser wird,
sind wieder andere dinge es steht alles voll weil ich musste halt alles auspacken war auch ganz
gut ich hab mal richtig inventur machen müssen allein schon um euch alle mit audio-interface und headsets zu versorgen weil wenn schon remote dann wenigstens ein ordentlicher qualität nicht wahr
und in dem zusammenhang habe ich halt mal so eine komplett inventur meiner headsets gemacht einschließlich eines tests was denn überhaupt funktioniert was nicht funktioniert kabel aussortiert also eine sache gemacht dann habe ich äh audiointerface gekauft,
um sie euch auf den tisch stellen zu können und verschiedene ausprobiert und einige wieder für schlecht befunden
ja und dann letztlich die auswahl getroffen die ihr da auf dem tisch stehen habt ihr verwendet jetzt alle einen fokus rein fokus right,
scarlett solo genau also mit einem mikrofon anschluss dritte generation ganz wichtig die ersten beiden generationen will ich.
Es hat schon viel schönes finde ich also auch so äußerlich und.
Alle nein nicht alle.
Nur der huckel der der huckel hatte ja schon der hat ja.
Pose hat natürlich wieder equipment.
Klar der ist ja auch ein musiker stimmt rudi ist auch schon vor konfiguriert gewesen.
Ja ich habe dieses dieses.
Podcaste durch ein motor acht zwei acht.
Dass das gute alte alesia zwei express ein logo plastikbomber vor dem herrn aber es tut.
Loco plastikbomber schön ja leute.
Ja es ist etwas partner sehr plastik hier anmutung aber es tut und es ist nicht allzu schwer man kann's überall mit hinnehmen.
Gut ich werde mal hier auch mal unseren chat der ja immer mitläuft und der auch fleißig bevölkert wird auch gleich mal mit links versorgen ihr wisst es ganz wichtig was nicht im chat steht landet nachher nicht in den shownotes
ja dieses fokus right ist in der tat ganz empfehlenswert weil es ist nicht nur hübsch sonst funktioniert offensichtlich auch ganz gut und ist kompakt was ich ehrlich gesagt als am,
das interessanteste feature finde ich habe jetzt allerdings diese.
Es hat ja erfrischend wenig knöpfe diese dinge haben ja gerne mal die eigenschaft die obskures knöpfe zu haben nicht ob's kurse weil ich an den fokus halt entdeckt habe aber dieser instagram knopf wo du mich dann aber aufgeklärt hast
nicht instagram ist sondern instrument meinte oder sowas war doch mal.
Na ja solche solche audiointerface sind ja klassischerweise immer für musiker
und musiker machen ja nur zwei dinge entweder sie singen oder sie spielen gitarre und dass der mikrofoneingang ist halt zum singen und der andere eingang ist halt zum gitarre spielen und das kriegst du den halt nicht ausgetrieben also haben diese interfaces,
dann hat es noch.
Er interface diese knopf würde ich gerne wissen.
Ja weiß nicht huckel kannst du das irgendwie erläutern was sie da machen.
Das simuliert ein etwas höherwertigen von focus reit dann klingt das alles ganz eric sozusagen also die haben ja die bauen ja schon lange
und der hat den mal vor langer zeit quasi flaggschiff design gezaubert,
und mit diesem button da stellen sie halt so ein bisschen rum damit der der da viel günstiger ist in diesem solo so ein bisschen so klingt wieder teurer.
Und wenn man das jetzt haben oder nicht so für podcast.
Kannst du weglassen ist also ich halte das für einen unnötigen knopf.
Ein unnötiger knopf na das ist doch auch was.
Aber irgendwie bei mir funktioniert grade das monitoring in der tat nicht also dass ich mich selbst höre nein es war halt angeschalten.
Muss man direct monitor oben rechts mal.
Genau und wenn ich das anmache höre ich euch jetzt also jetzt ist es aus jetzt höre ich euch ein bisschen lauter hör mich immer noch nicht wenn ich's jetzt anmache jetzt endlich ich bin wirklich so leise könnt ihr mal kurz was sagen.
Ja du bist weil du dein game runtergedreht hast du kannst dann gehen ja auch wieder raufdrehen dann haben wir natürlich noch mehr.
Aber dann hört ihr das rauschen.
Das haben wir.
Nein ist alles gut.
Mach dich ruhig ein bisschen lauter.
Ich bin voll irritiert wenn man.
Hinterher wieder weg.
Willst du mit mir gehen.
Ja
Das nehme ich jetzt persönlich oder war das die antwort auf huckel,
mann mann mann mann mann mann mann irgendwas wollte ich gerade sagen.
Gesichtsausdruck dazu nicht gesehen.
Nee das stimmt ich,
also so ein so ein audiointerface auf jeden fall was ganz nettes weil ich habe jetzt natürlich das andere problem dass ich,
ich bin also es fällt mir nicht leicht zu klagen weil an sich ist ja alles in ordnung aber trotzdem,
hat mich natürlich diese krise wie so viele von uns zum falschen zeitpunkt ich hatte nämlich gerade in der woche also alles auf einmal runter fuhr.
Eine extrem detaillierte seit wochen im detail geplant podcast kreise eingeplant,
und hätte in fünf
tagen ganze sechs interviews aufgenommen quer durch deutschland das ist mal gar nicht so einfach das alles zu koordinieren dass die leute zeit haben und dass ich das alles ergibt und dass ich in der einen stadt aufnehme und genug zeit habe einzupacken und dann in zug und dann nächste stadt und da aufnehmen und so weiter und hier ein hotel und dann wieder weiter
und von den sechs terminen sind natürlich am ende zwei übrig geblieben,
verständlicherweise aber ja sonst hätte ich irgendwie mein ganzes interview material bis bis bis mai juni schon fertig im kasten gehabt und das viel natürlich dann alles weg und jetzt muss ich mir natürlich auch überlegen
ob ich für meine interview podcast also sowas wie forschergeist und raum zeit
über den über das stückchen springe und tatsächlich mal sowas aus der ferne mache.
Was ich ja aus verschiedensten gründen eigentlich sehr ungern tue oder eben gar nicht tue
naja deswegen muss ich mir halt natürlich jetzt auch equipment zusammensuchen und dann hast du halt immer das problem die leute haben halt einfach schlechte ausrüstung also internet haben sie natürlich alle gute headsets haben sie natürlich alle fast nie
und wenn ich den halt ein gutes headset schicke dann muss ich ihnen wie euch auch so ein audiointerface bereitstellen dann ist natürlich die frage wo kommt denn,
dann das audio lang und ich hatte jetzt verschiedene termine auch wo leute,
dieses linux benutzt haben und ich kann euch sagen es hat sich in diesen zwang letzten zwanzig jahren.
Mal bitte nochmal.
Es hat sich,
louis nix es hat sich einfach in den letzten zwanzig jahren nichts verbessert auf diesem system es ist eine totale katastrophe also alle einfach ein fucking headset anzuschließen
audio auf der einen seite rein auf der anderen seite raus das ist wirklich alles was ich von diesem system verlange es scheint nicht möglich zu sein ist es wirklich.
Ich helfe dir jetzt mal tim und teile jetzt mal den hass der jetzt sofort in den nächsten drei vier fünf ab
drei vier fünf sekunden auf die nieder prasselt und stimme dir zu linux ist ein geiles service system aber wer sich auf dem desktop tut der hat echt mal so tendenzen.
Es ist ich meine ich bin ja bereit zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass es sich das geändert hat ja,
aber das kann einfach nicht sein dass man im jahr zwanzig zwanzig eine stunde lang die buggy machen muss,
um am ende dann einfach zu sagen so komm nimm dein iphone und dann machen wir es halt damit,
so schlimm so also jetzt muss ich natürlich auf alles vorbereitet sein und hab dann überlegt okay was
was schicke ich den leuten weil mein plan ist ich habe jetzt schon so eine so eine so eine box hier stehen kann ich euch auch mal zeigen also so eine kleine
plastik box die sich gut verschließen lässt schöne kleine euro box und
die ist dann halt entsprechend befüllt mit zeug da ist also dann ein headset drin und ein audiointerface und dann kommt da noch so ein paar kabel und adapter und netzteile und all so ein kram mit rein.
Und noch so ein.
Na ja es gab ja es gab ja mal wenn ihr euch erinnert als diese ganze studiolink sache losging was wir jetzt hier auch verwenden den plan das eigentlich mit so einer kleinen hardware box zu machen,
ja die gibt es im prinzip immer noch nur da hat sich natürlich die ganze softwareentwicklung komplett auf die lösung auf dem rechner konzentriert was auch sinnvoll ist weil da passiert nun mal,
am meisten und da hat man am meisten flexibilität und das benutze ich ja jetzt hier auch gerade
nur dass eben diese ganze idee mit man hat da so eine box die man hinstellt und es ist vollkommen egal welcher computer dann da noch im raum steht,
das ist halt irgendwie vorbei und dann hast du auch das problem.
Du weißt aber schon dass er den denn noch wenigstens bei deinem remote kunden wie ins netz bringen musste das heißt schlimmstenfalls im wlan einbuchen und das ist auch schon wieder zu viel.
Ja genau genau genau genau weil die dann nämlich oft auch nur wlan haben oder natürlich haben die irgendwo einen router stehen der auch hinten noch eine buchse hat aber was weiß ich wo die dann steht und dann wissen sie nicht was.
Deine zeitforscher sitzt in ihrem institut und da hat natürlich irgendein faschos atmet das ganze ding zugeknallt da kannst du dich nicht mehr ins wlan einbuchen ist so.
Ja
Du kannst so ein kleine nano router mitschicken da muss nur laden rein oder sim-karte und.
Ich baue dir ein set ab das ist dann komplett da machst du nur noch aufklappen von deiner box und das ding telefoniert heim und alles ist gut.
Geht natürlich davon aus dass es überall gibt ne.
Ja gibt es die leute die du interviewen willst die haben alle zu hause.
Da komme ich vielleicht noch mal drauf zu da komme ich vielleicht wirklich nochmal drauf zurück zurück trotzdem brauche.
Weil dann hast du nur auf clubbing dann musst du nicht mit also nochmal ist jetzt nicht so dass leute zu dem ich werde jetzt sachen ins wlan einzubuchen aber es gibt
gerade in firmen und institutionen ihr habt sehr häufig gesehen gerade bei bei wissenschafts dingern oder sowas die haben immer besonders geile faschos admins
musst du einen account oder irgendwie sowas haben und den hat natürlich deine box nicht und blauen blub und hin und her deswegen
wenn du das einfach machen willst dann machst du eine kiste da hast du einen teilchen drin schick sie den leuten zu und tschüss.
Ja
Strom an und stream und bla fertig
sonst ärgerst du dich für ein für ein ein stunden interview fünf stunden rum mit denen das ist ja aber wenn der typ jetzt nicht im keller neben seinem abgeschirmten reaktor sitzt dann dann hast du da eigentlich
wo so forscher rumhopsen.
Bei mir ist es so da wo ich jetzt wohne da ist irgendwie drei häuser weiter ist die große antenne von der telekom also ich habe hier wirklich überall volle bewaltigung,
und wenn dann leute kommen die nur so opfer sind die kriegen hier halt nicht mal irgendwie richtig.
Deswegen wird tim da natürlich auch kein tusem hinschicken wenn er einigermaßen hirn hat.
Selbstredend wollte ich jetzt noch gar nicht drauf eingehen den teil aber you for out of my also wirklich absurd.
Ja das ist eine schöne idee wobei.
Es sind ja auch die deren während wir uns jetzt in klötzchen wusste von netflix und amazon prime ergeben müssen.
Da kommen aber genau schon zum.
Aber kommen wir später drauf.
Kommen wir nämlich zum nächsten punkt ist ne also wie stelle ich sozusagen sicher dass das ding internet hat und dann könnte ich ja im prinzip das wäre schon fast die eleganteste lösung fast sogar noch besser als in der studie die box ich könnte mir einfach ein iphone nehmen,
was ich über habe und das einfach eingebucht ist dann sehe ich nämlich auch schon welche das verschicke wo es ist im idealfall und das ist eigentlich eine echt gute idee hab ich da nicht schon früh auf.
Machst du ein audiointerface dran fertig.
Da habe ich die karte drin pipapo da ist die app drauf,
und muss die muss natürlich irgendwie ein lok dauern an diesem telefon machen dass da auch nicht sehr viel mehr läuft als diese app könnte auch schwierig werden dass man sagen gedanken drüber machen.
Kannst du den kindern den kinderforschungstag anders machen du hast auch kinder du weißt doch wie man iphones konnte kontrolliert oder.
Lass uns nicht damit anfangen das ist nochmal ein ganz anderer untergrund auf jeden fall,
das audiointerface was du da jetzt gerade verwendest clemens möchte natürlich gerne,
nicht nur per daten mit dir verbunden werden sondern ich möchte natürlich gerne von deinem computer auch strom haben weil du schließt ja ja kein netzteil an,
so ein iphone liefert aber diesen strom nicht.
Schweinegeld ei.
Der schweinegeld deswegen habe ich nochmal geguckt und es gibt,
ein anderes interface ist nämlich das was hier schon in dieser box drin habe dass nämlich von steinberg das ist im prinzip dasselbe wie dieses fokus reit ist bloß irgendwie größer warum auch immer und hat aber einen kleinen schalter hinten wo man sagen kann
auch wenn der usb daten reinkommt,
deine power kommt von der anderen box und dann ist er noch ein kleiner mikro usb c-stecker und dann kann ich da einfach nochmal ein netzteil reinstecken und dann funktioniert das auch ja.
Zu fragen tim gibt's dieses focus right nicht auch mit einem lightning interface und wenn ja wie wird das gepowert.
Sowas nein.
Mal bitte auf deinem du hast ja eh gerade dein thomann katalog offen hier auf dem screen auf aufm beamer ähm ich glaube es gibt diese fokus reiz scarlett gibt's auch mit lightning-anschluss.
Das das wäre.
Nicht mein leben darauf verwenden aber ich dachte ich hätte sowas neulich an mir vorbeiziehen sehen.
Auf jeden fall fokus right mit usb c aber.
Mit lightning.
Also es gibt so naja es gibt so eine mini mini focus red-box irgendwo habe ich das auch schon mal gesehen warte mal aber die sich bei thomann gerade nicht was nicht unbedingt heißen muss dass sie nicht gibt aber.
Also audiointerface es gibt irgendwelche lösungen ja du willst ja auch dass es ordentlich klingt und lightning wäre mir jetzt neu dass das dabei ist.
Ich habe neulich mal nach diesem fokus weil etwas mehr geschickt hast mal geklickt einfach mal um zu sehen was wo das herkommt so und ich glaube da zog was an mir vorbei in irgendeiner auswahlmenü mit lightning.
Track solo heißt das es ist ein.
Das ist auch ein solo.
Die weiß.
Track solo.
Das ist aber nicht von focus schreitet heißt bloß auch solo.
Doch du bist von focus,
aber das hat was hat das mal.
So und die kriegt.
Und wie koppelt sich das.
Wird das entsprechende kabel drin sein.
Wahrscheinlich musst du da ein lightning usb stecker haben am ende.
Nee der hat bestimmt kein lightning.
Der usb mini und usb zwei.
Ja das ding habe ich auch gesehen aber was was was was was macht das zu einem also wo ist da der unterschied zu dem anderen außer dass.
Stand da was mit lightning warte mal ich muss jetzt mal den.
Vielleicht verbraucht es weniger strom.
Oder wird durch blitzer gespeist wer weiß weiß link.
Kabel inklusive hat die haben halt einfach einen anderen noch ein kabel dabei.
Aber da hast du die weiße link das heißt sie haben denn aber sich überlegt wo man da strom reinkriegt in der ding sonst würdet ja keinen sinn machen.
Mit dem externe usb dings da kannst du noch strom dazu.
Aber nur in den usa zumindest es nur dort dabei.
Norbert was tim haben will er möchte gerne extern strom reinmachen und dann irgendwie per lightning wie die weißte anschließen.
Lightning kompatibel ach guck an aber wieso gibt's denn kein foto von der rückseite ja für den scheißteil.
Nur auf amazon bist guck doch mal auf der richtigen seite.
Stimmt.
Der dieses ding da mal bei thomann.
Bei focus right gibt's das ok ich.
Ein kind ein device und ein usb zwei und nachdem da in ein light dabei ist nehme ich mal an dass du style auch beim rechner ganz normal am rechner benutzen kannst und es gibt sogar einen slot verein kensington schloss,
kannst du es an der an der kiste fest schnuppern.
Einfach das iphone direkt drauf kleben.
Das ist in der tat.
Das sieht vom prinzip aus wie diese ding was wir hier auch haben mit noch weniger noch weniger knödel dran und jetzt die rückseite bitte.
Hier ist.
Da ist die rückseite da hast du power wahrscheinlich über usb zwei da kannst du schmeißt du so ein standard netzteil mit rein,
und die weiße link da machst du irgendwie keine ahnung wie denn dein lightning kabel oder wieso war dran willst du nicht liefern sehr mit so hast du doch schon.
Gitarristen kannst du auch interviewen.
Genau gitarristen kannst du auch interview.
Das ist in der tat ganz interessant und dann einfach noch ein telefon dazu.
Kannst du wenn's auch ich weiß dass es jetzt gegen die religion aber ich sitze ja weit genug weg gerade von dir,
kannst du auch ein android-telefon nehmen und da auch ein grund war ja beziehungsweise den kleinen bruder drauf spielen dann hast du auch studiolink,
nochmal andere möglichkeiten der tut dir das auch nicht ganz so weh wenn der paketbote der ding verschluckt,
ok ich hab's nicht gesagt.
Aber bist du bist du so viele android gekauft hast um eins zu finden das funktioniert.
Guckst du grade mal ob er noch ob er noch zuckt er scheint irgendwie so einen herzinfarkt zu haben der tim.
Bier nachgefüllt so schlimm kann es nicht sein mit dem herzinfarkt.
Okay ich werde das mal bestellen mal gucken vielleicht funktioniert das ja sogar.
Hier bewahre dein feng shui weniger kabel bedeuten auch weniger unordnung.
Hätte ich mir auch nicht träumen lassen jemals dass ich in der lage bin mal tim audiointerface zu empfehlen.
Tja so ist das gut jetzt haben wir aber.
Dieser times du solltest du noch lernen dass der track heißt und nicht track wurde jetzt schon zum fünften.
Ja ist ja in ordnung ich mache ich mache das als kriterien gleich aus ja penner,
so lass uns mal zu anderen themen kommen während ich hier im hintergrund bestelle,
wir müssen über den elefanten im raum sprechen irgendwie ihr so damit klarkommt also rudi hat man ja schon der ist dem dem tod von der schippe gesprungen,
oder rudi.
Sieht zwar nicht so aus entschuldigung.
Hallo.
Entschuldigung das war jetzt einfach nur die vorlage ist unfair gewesen aber die vorlage war einfach.
Weiß nicht genau wie weit ich auf der schippe gesessen habe also das ist so aber.
Wer sie lassen sich ja nicht testen ne du bist immer noch um getestet nach wie vor.
Ich bin angetestet ja es gilt nach wie vor ich bin dunkelziffer.
Dabei dabei geben sie an wie ein sack flöhe dass wir in deutschland die meisten tester überhaupt sind weltweit aber ein rudi kriegen sie nicht getestet das haben wir.
Ja weil die test kapazitäten absolut überlastet sind und die haben gerade genug damit zu tun das medizinische personal und die risiko fälle abzutesten zumindest.
Das ist richtig das war aber vor zweieinhalb wochen noch nicht so,
und da waren sie auch schon sehr groß also ich habe inzwischen auch von sehr sehr vielen leuten gehört durch diesen podcast die alle gesagt haben ja genau der gleiche fall bei ihnen sie haben es einfach nicht geschafft ein test zu bekommen.
Und selbst wenn dauert's halt zwei drei tage.
Also wenn wenn der antikörper test kommt dann werden sie den wahrscheinlich wieder nicht in die masse streuen und irgendwann ist dann auch einfach egal.
Wieso werden sie die nicht in die masse streuen das doch der ganze sinn der ganzen sache.
Ach da finden sich bestimmt gründe.
Es ist halt cool um tatsächlich im im nachhinein halt so die durchdringung von dem virus und auch die ganzen dunkelziffern so ein bisschen abzufangen das problem ist dass gerade für akut patienten der antikörper test nicht viel sinn macht weil du halt,
eine gewisse zeit an tagen brauchst um die antikörper entwickelt zu haben und das heißt für das ist dann so,
also ich habe aber irgendwo gehört dass es zumindestens jetzt die ersten kleinen dörfer durchtesten wollen um da halt zu analysieren wie sich das ganze verteilt hat.
Es gibt glaube ich eine gemeinde in münchen die das extrem tun will die wollen sozusagen wirklich mal alle durchtesten ich weiß nicht war das die die,
davon betroffen war dass da diese ersten skiurlauber vorbeigekommen sind weil sie immer so ganz genau,
und der andere plan der jetzt gerade bekannt geworden ist von dem ich aber noch nicht genau weiß wie konkret er ist und wann der wirklich loslegt ist halt wirklich,
das gezielte stichproben testen so wo sie dann eine bestimmte random meist grob über einen zeitraum von keine ahnung länger,
regelmäßig immer wieder testen wollen in der größenordnung von hunderttausend leuten um damit dann eben eine allgemeine aussage treffen zu können.
Ist ja auch spannend denke ich für diese ganze herde immunität geschichte also jetzt im nachgang mal raus zu herauszufinden wie wie das ist sind sie ja immer noch nicht komplett einig ob man jetzt dann nur immun ist weil in welche chinesen haben behauptet dass es jetzt schon zum zweiten mal hatten.
Vierzehn prozent vierzehn prozent ist jetzt eine studie.
Dass sie wohl nie richtig ausgeheilt waren also es gibt wohl zweifel an dieser studie zumindest dieser resource affen test war ja relativ eindeutig die affen die das einmal hatten die haben sie auch mit mit massiven dosen nicht wieder infiziert bekommen,
insofern wäre würde ich mir da jetzt nicht so große gedanken machen.
Du bist doch unsere unser medizinisches bis unser medizinisches personal.
Ich bin kein experte ich bin kein experte ich kriege den charité news lecker schmecker.
Habe ich nicht gesagt ich habe nur gesagt dass du unser medizinisches personal bist also noch eher als ich auf jeden fall.
Vielleicht hast du denn eine konkrete frage so dass ich dich an den experten verweisen kann.
Nee also ich meine ich habe ja hier auf ukw jetzt schon ein paar gespräche mit leuten aus dem zerrt gesprochen da hängst du ja auch ein bisschen mit drin ich nehme mal an du bist da auch empfänger dieses täglichen bulle teens und der täglichen.
Den chat abonniert ich krieg quasi die ressourcen für das politik.
Verstehe genauso da ist ja sozusagen nochmal einen anderen seismograph an dem an dem ganzen geschehen hast du das gefühl dass derzeit,
also was ist denn so was sagt denn so dass das das medizin personal barometer sind da alle eher so entspannt oder nervös oder aufgeregt oder in panik,
in deutschland.
Nicht panik die können sich keine panik leisten,
ich weiß dass berlin noch gut vorbereitet ist aber die rechnen alle mit einer ordentlichen spitze und dann mit ähnlichen maßnahmen wie in italien und,
belgien spanien auch new york also,
es ist wahrscheinlich dass nicht,
alle personen beatmet werden können mit den derzeitigen ressourcen es fehlt halt wie überall erwähnt an desinfektionsmitteln mundschutz schutzkleidung etcetera p weil,
unser gesamtes gesundheitssystem für alle etwas unbefriedigend ist gelinde ausgedrückt,
aber da gibt es mehr als genug leute die halt im prinzip an der front sind und direkt auf die probleme hinweisen und da sollte man dann vielleicht halt eher den zuhören.
Ich meine wir haben ja jetzt wie lange sitzen wir jetzt schon zuhause zwei wochen ungefähr ne oder.
Keine ahnung setz dich doch nicht geändert.
Ja okay gut das ist.
For life.
Der der der nerd faktor ja genauso das ist
das ist natürlich so unser ding ne also alle so quarantäne wie furchtbar die ganze zeit zu hause sitzen und alle dazu normal war
aber das das ist natürlich für uns ein psychologischer vorteil aber dass der nicht unbedingt jetzt für alle leute geht es gut und wir hätten natürlich zwischendurch auch noch mal ein paar andere ambitionen so ist ja jetzt auch nicht,
und ich sehe auch schon meine akribische sommerferien plan langsam dahin sie kann,
was wollte ich jetzt gerade fragen habe ich vergessen ich wollte irgendwas sagen sag du mal was taler.
Ich hab alles gesagt.
Du hast gefragt wir sitzen schon seit zwei wochen zu hause vielleicht.
Ach so ja genau ja ja jetzt weiß ich wieder uns also wir haben ja jetzt zwei wochen schon durch wann ist denn damit zu rechnen dass man sehen kann ob das was gebracht hat und wie viel es gebracht hat in einer woche in zwei.
Das das gemeine ist ja wenn wir tatsächlich,
im prinzip diese inflationsrate so reduziert bekommen dass das system nicht überlastet ist,
kriegt man im idealfall das gar nicht so richtig mit weil hält alles so business läuft,
das heißt du hast nicht diesen krassen vergleich und das ist dann auch im prinzip diese diese überlebens bei ist es war ja gar nicht so schlimm,
weil wir halt uns selbst isoliert haben um das halt irgendwie zu vermeiden das ist so ein.
Da habe ich aber am meisten angst vor weil die ganzen populisten die jetzt alle rumschreien die christian lindner ist dieser welt oder sowas die werden natürlich alle auf den zug aufspringen sagen sowas wie wir haben jetzt keinen tee gemacht und das war's jetzt,
ja das ist sozusagen immer das problem dabei das ähnlich wie wenig wie eine versicherung oder so ja wo man dann auch sagt ja jetzt ist alles gut gegangen warum habe ich deine versicherung gezahlt ja,
wieso.
Ja also es ist halt noch ein bisschen bisschen anderer effekt weil,
das ist ja tatsächlich unser verhalten beeinflusst ist und sobald wir das verhältnis also dieses verhalten ändern würden,
sobald jetzt plötzlich schulen kitas spielplätze wieder geöffnet werden und alle business machen haben wir halt plötzlich wieder den potentiellen anstieg,
und das ist dann das wird dann halt schnell uncool.
Das heißt sozusagen jetzt auch ein bisschen kern meiner frage wie wie kriegt man denn das jetzt eigentlich modelliert meine wir müssen alle in dem moment wo es
wo einer von zwei fällen eintreffen würde würde sich die situation verändern erstens es gibt irgendein extrem wirksames medikament um die symptome,
einzuschränken was noch nicht absehbar ist und natürlich es gibt einen impfstoff,
also wenn's ein gäbe so dann,
wird man einfach mal alle ordentlich durch pieksen und dann ist das ding halt auch durch so das kann halt nur sein dass das eben jetzt noch bei medikamenten ja und bei dem impfstoff zwei jahre dauert oder also.
Und dann kannst du dir ausrechnen wann das masern impfmittel rausgeht masern impfstoff in die breite masse gebracht wurde und wie lange es bis zum jetzigen impfskandal bis kommt so dass wir das in spätestens zwanzig jahren dann nochmal den spaß haben.
Na gut aber in zwanzig jahren nehme ich jetzt erstmal so mit so na dann ist zumindest genug zeit um sich dann später nochmal darüber aufzuregen so aber jetzt ist ja sozusagen kurzfristig
problem dass dass diese auswirkungen global sind und wahrscheinlich wird's also diese woche in den usa nochmal richtig explodieren,
tippe auch mal dass wir in indien und bangladesch und solchen gegenden wird's auch nochmal richtig knallen und pakistan keine ahnung was die so für maßnahmen da schon hoch gefahren haben,
aber das sind natürlich alles so auch orte mit mit bevölkerungsdichte da wird's sehr schwierig werden da irgendwas zu container,
was heißt die auswirkung auf die globale wirtschaft werden dann doch enorm sein.
Ja sind sie jetzt.
Sind sie sind sie jetzt schon aber jetzt ist es halt gerade noch so im naja okay wenn es in zwei wochen vorbei ist dann kriegen wir uns schon wieder eingefangen aber wenn's jetzt halt noch ein halbes jahr so weitergeht dann wird's knifflig.
Na ja bei manchen
dinge die man da so hört von manchen leuten ist weiß man natürlich nicht wieso firmen fliegst du auch gerne mal ein bisschen übertreiben aber ich bin doch ein bisschen erstaunt wie fragil diese ganze geschichte dort ist,
ist klar dass jetzt jemand dass niemand darauf vorbereitet ist dass man jetzt ein halbes jahr oder länger wie alle zuhause sitzen aber wir sind jetzt in woche zwei und die haben ja schon in der ersten woche haben sie ja schon das große sterben ausgerufen von irgendwelchen firmen da.
Ging ja schon die ja schon vorher los.
Frag mich wirklich alter was was machst du wenn du dir mal ein bein brichst
und dann mal drei wochen im krankenhaus liegt oder zwei oder so da war ich wirklich ein bisschen überrascht wie wie doch sehr sehr fragil manche leute oder firmen oder wie man da sind.
Das hängt natürlich jetzt ja von der branche ab ne ich weiß jetzt nicht welche branche du meinst.
Kreuz und quer durch die ganze bank durch wo leute ich sagte schon in der letzten woche schon sagte wir sind tot und ich so alter du bist jetzt drei tage zuhause was was hast denn du wie hast du vorher sorgt für den unternehmen wenn du nach drei tagen ausfall dich
schon für tot deklariert.
Na gut ich meine da gibt's gibt's ein paar ganz gute erklärung immer da gibt's halt so läden die ohnehin schon kurz vor der insolvenz waren.
Klar.
Ja die gerade so versucht haben sie was weiß ich ja so war plane und marino und diese ganzen ketten wo alles auf kante genäht ist da hat man schon gehört dass es den ja vorher schon nicht gut ging die sind natürlich dann in so einer situation schnell geliefert,
dann hast du natürlich all die branchen wo klar ist dass selbst wenn morgen,
alle wieder arbeiten gehen würden und alle schulen angehen ihre,
branche einfach langfristig gescheitert ist also der ganze tourismus wer wer plant denn jetzt urlaub keiner alles ist abgesagt,
bis hotels sich von der situation wieder erholt haben und touristen orte und und und auch länder deren
in kam im wesentlichen von tourismus abhängt portugal die sich gerade erst wieder gefangen haben andere länder nordafrika marokko keine ahnung also alle die irgendwie vom tourismus leben da gibt's ja ganze,
starten die eigentlich nur davon leben spanien auch,
das vertrauen lässt sich ja so schnell nicht wieder herstellen bis die leute wirklich bereit sind zu sagen ich fahre jetzt mal hier und mach ballermann.
Das wird halt lange dauern und dann ist klar dass wir eben nicht nur von zwei wochen reden sondern die haben quasi die buchung für die nächsten zwei jahre storniert bekommen und dass das natürlich eine auswirkung hat ist auch klar,
dann hast du so bereiche die,
komplexe lieferketten haben da würde ich dir auch total zustimmen also das sind sicherlich die die jetzt mal drüber nachdenken müssen ob so ihr durch globalisiertes just in time system was sozusagen
auf einen absolut reibungslos dauerhaft funktionierenden flow hin optimiert sind und damit die kosten runterdrehen ob das nicht genug ob das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen mehr resilienz verdient hätte.
Na ja und dann hast du halt so alles dazwischen wo du eben so eine mischung hast aus ist sehr personalintensiv gastronomiebereiches sind natürlich jetzt auch enorm bedroht die,
alle die in irgendeiner form veranstaltungen machen veranstaltungsorte,
veranstalter agenturen die haben nichts zu tun mehr also gar nichts und die wissen vor allem auch nicht wann sich das wieder ändert,
also da ist ja auch noch so ein unsicherheitsfaktor drin wenn du sagen kannst na ja in zwei wochen sind die schulen wieder auf klar dann haben die lehrer wieder etwas zu tun dann haben die caterer wieder was zu tun dann wird auch wieder klopapier in die schulen verkauft das ist alles absehbar.
Ich glaube dieser geschäftszweig hat momentan den größten reibach oder.
Sie haben aber das problem und das hat in planet money ganz gut jetzt vor kurzem nochmal gezeigt die haben jetzt dann hoch sind darauf überhaupt nicht vorbereitet weil die offenen gleichbleibendes
klopapier niveau eigentlich eingepegelt sind damit jetzt einen highkick und danach kommt das tal,
die haben halt auch ein problem wenn sie da nicht drüber nachdenken sind die auch ganz schnell hops gegangen also es ist halt,
eine abhängigkeit schon da drin wo man unternehmerisch sehr schlau herangehen muss auch.
Also diese klopapier sache ist natürlich super interessant also erstmal so als kulturelles phänomen ne also warum haben auf einmal alle so viele schiss dass sie,
was ist
interessanter psychologischer moment ne sozusagen die leute denken darüber nach so oh gott was ist jetzt das wichtigste und ich will gar nicht mal sagen dass klopapier das am meisten nachgefragte produkt ist es ist nur etwas was du normalerweise in den,
du kaufst es selten aber dann immer in großen mengen und das unter klopapier halt sehr leicht ist,
und sehr viel raum einnimmt,
aber auch nicht viel gewinnmarge abläuft und an sich nicht oft gekauft wird nimmt es halt auch nicht so viel schief space ein das heißt die supermärkte haben einfach nur platz für dreißig einheiten oder sowas im gegensatz zu was weiß ich
backpulver irgendwie da haben sie halt in einem regal haben sie tausend einheiten wenn's wenn's sein muss so aber klopapier nimmt halt viel platz an,
hefe all diese ganzen.
Hierfür ist ja auch ausverkauft mehl auch.
Ja mir auch genau aber aber das wird sich relativ schnell wieder einfangen weil da ist auch genug da,
und das kriegst du auch relativ schnell in so einem lastwagen bestückt aber du kannst jetzt nicht sagen ich fahre jetzt hier mein zweiundzwanzig komplett nur mit klopapier durch die gegend weil dann ist er einfach nicht ordentlich ausgelastet,
also gewichtsmäßig nicht.
Einfach nicht an.
Der.
Der wird auf der straße weggefangen.
Fahren jetzt nur noch markiert.
Ich fand ich fand ja diesen bäcker so geil der irgendwie aus gag so klopapier kuchen gebacken hat,
also runden marmorkuchen mit ein bisschen von dorn dran und dann haben die ihm die leute die bude eingerannt und haben diese komischen klopapier kuchen weggekauft.
Nichts schlägt.
Viel lustiger pfand war so ein so ein angebot für sie nicht amazon oder ebay wo jemand kassen druckrollen verkauft hat also weißt du so diese für kassen diese diese kassen papier diese thermo papier.
Hallo.
Und es sah auf dem bild obwohl fett drauf stand dass der thermomix papier für kassen ist sah das aus wie so eine wie so eine.
Klopapier.
Haben sie ihm weggekauft und sich alle hinterher bitter beschwert also wirklich das fand ich ja sowieso.
Ja ja aber das ist sozusagen das klopapier problem allerdings und da habe ich jetzt auch schon mal einen praktischen link jeder von euch der dasselbe problem hat das wurde mir über einen anderen hörer zugetragen,
der hersteller illi oder das sind die marke heißt ich weiß gar nicht dass der laden ja die marke die firma heißt wahrscheinlich so die haben nämlich sozusagen genau dieses problem,
dass sie,
eigentlich tonnenweise klopapier haben ist aber gerade nicht loswerden weil die gastro ist ihnen nicht abkauft und die caterer nicht abkauft die schulen nicht abkaufen ist twitterer
und sie aber eben nicht ohne weiteres mehr in die märkte kriegen können weil die einfach diese,
lieferwege nicht haben das kann ich jetzt nicht ganz genau erklären warum das nicht funktioniert aber es hat ja auch alles was mit zentraler einkauf zu tun bei edeka rewe etcetera dann wird sozusagen alles ja erst mal dahin geliefert und von dort dann verteilt also sie können nicht einfach
dynamisch selber als anbieter ohne weiteres rein pushen also haben sie jetzt angefangen.
Fahrrad korea.
Selber ist ja nicht nur fahrrad ich meine diese klopapierrolle keine ahnung wo die normalerweise rumstehen und produziert werden auf jeden fall wäre jetzt klopapier braucht kann unter anderem dort direkt beim hersteller bestellen und dann kommt das halt einfach.
Werksverkauf.
Quasi ja also halt mit per lieferdienst ne,
kannst vielleicht auch zum werk fahren also wer in der nähe von einem klopapier hersteller wohnt er hat wahrscheinlich eh schon ausgesorgt.
Da gab es am anfang dieser ganzen klopapier kalypso gab's ja so ein video was ich rumgetrieben hat von unserem holländer,
gabelstaplerfahrer ist in so einem werk von so einem ding,
wie in sein handy reingrannt und meinte wie was klopapier problem und dann saß du ihn fahren mit seinem gabelstapler in dieser halle hinein die sich in die unendlichkeit streckte mit
unendlich hohen regalen alles voll mit klopapier und er so ja klopapier schottet schnee ist klar ja.
Noch wir haben noch.
Noch.
Ja es gibt genug aber ist halt die logistik es zu verteilen das ist halt nochmal eine ganz andere geschichte.
Willst du doch mal den link in den chat in diesen shop-link ich habe zwar.
Ich habe das in den falschen kanal reingetan stelle ich gerade fest sorry.
Kann ich mit anderen tipp geben wo es zumindestens am freitag.
Kein ding also ich habe ja noch klopapier bei mir in kreuzberg gibt's auch noch club.
Hier auf dem land auch.
Genau rainer hat ja auch schon den schönen klopapier calculator da gibt es ja auch verschiedene gepostet.
Bei der ist doch wieder nur von männern gemacht muss man mal vielleicht festhalten.
Interessanter punkt genau ja erklär uns doch mal bitte auf über die spezifische verbrauchs profile von männern und frauen auf toilette.
Zuhörer und zuhören der zuhörerinnen werden das problem mehr kenntnis auf der toilette.
Alle personen mit uterus.
Und solche ist ja auch scheißegal wer halt auch immer aufs klo geht und nicht nur zum kacken das klopapier benötigt der braucht halt mehr so long story short.
Schön gesagt.
Also es ist halt sie gehen davon aus dass du zweimal am tag stuhlgang,
oder halt irgendwie wie auch immer du kannst es einstellen aber wenn du halt ein mehr geschlechtlicher haushalt bist sagt es dir nichts aus.
Verstehe was würdest du denn meinen wie lange klopapierrolle reicht.
Das habe ich mich heute auch gefragt als ich unsere neue angebrochen habe und ich würde meinen eine woche.
Eine woche echt boah.
Wir sind zu zweit weiß ich nicht ich glaube eine woche fünf tage ich werde es warte ich werde es notieren ich werde in der nächsten freakshow berichten.
Oh
Der tat das verändert hat mein erster gedanke heute auf dem klo.
Mach doch mal.
Wir machen einfach eine dezentrale datensammlung.
Blätter genau ich hätte gerne dass du die blätter einzeln nummeriert.
Genau ich sehe ein googles brett gibt's das auch durchnummeriert das wäre doch mal.
Genau gibt's das auch durch nummer.
Hallo.
Aber rückwärts bitte.
Oh ja.
Oh ja das ist eine gute idee warte mal da muss ich das mal kurz kurz gucken ich bin mir sicher das internet.
Nummeriert das klopapier.
Ja hat sowas schon irgendwie.
Das dann so eine art adventskalender.
Hallo.
Gibt es bestimmt auch
auf jeden fall ist es ein interessantes kulturelles phänomen dass halt die hamster drei da anfängt und es ist halt noch zusätzlich mit dieser komponente dieser distributions problematik und diesen spezifischen parkformat was
klopapier nun einfach mal hat es ist irgendwie wichtig und vor allem ist es halt wenn du mal über alle produkte nachdenkst die du auf jeden fall,
dauerhaft immer sicher in ausreichenden mengen zuhause haben willst würde würde dir da so sehr viel einfallen,
ja milch ist genau kaffee.
Das ist auch der ganze grund warum sich die leute auf klopapier stürzen weil sich sagen okay jetzt zinslosen zeit geld weil ich darin investiere selbst wenn ich sie erst in drei jahre anbrechen in drei jahren anbrechen diese eine packung.
Wird ja nicht schlecht.
Nicht schlecht alles andere wird halt oder nicht alles andere aber das meiste anne wird ja irgendwie schlecht aber klopapier kann man halt eben schön horten ohne sich damit in den fuß zu schießen,
nudeln auch.
Nudeln halten.
Egal war auch leer und dirk des konserven konserven suppen regal war auch leer.
Aber selektiv also hier bei dem supermarkt wo ich einkaufe kann es ja durchaus sagen jetzt ist wäre denn zum beispiel in rheinsberg der hat so selektiv regale die sind entweder komplett leer,
oder noch fast voll zum beispiel nudel regal ist nicht komplett leer da sind bestimmte nudelsorten sind leer die auch schon seit.
Riesa wahrscheinlich oder.
Keine ahnung
jetzt mal auf die schilder die schilder hängen ja da noch kannst du gucken eigentlich wetter ist aber denkst du arbeitest nicht das gesamte nudel regal ja das geht jetzt nicht so 'n luxusmarke sondern geht es um bestimmte typen.
Lasagne blätter war noch da.
Das hat aber auch.
Cannelloni die sind noch.
Könnte sein.
Aber es gab doch dieses tolle bild da aus italien oder aus dem supermarkt in teilen wo alle barilla nur den weg waren nur die vollkornnudeln war noch da.
Übrigens zum thema toilettenpapier werde ja ganz drauf verzichten will ja ich habe hier mal kurz was ins lack gepostet das hat ein,
ein typ den ich folge gepostet sondern quasi upgrade für die toilette zu hause in einem d zu verwandeln,
es sieht so aus wie es klingt nicht besonders,
hochwertig wahrscheinlich auf dauer aber das wäre natürlich dann auch noch eine variante ich weiß nicht wie man da das wasser rankriegt ob man da den dusch schlauch anschließen kann oder so aber.
Es gibt ja so andere länder auch gar nicht so weit weg ich möchte jetzt gar nicht von den high end japanischen toiletten die auch mal wieder ein knaller sind jedes mal wenn ich da bin freue ich mich darüber
aber es gibt auch in finnland in finnland hängt auch eigentlich neben jeder toilette auch im öffentlichen sogar so eine mini,
browser also so eine mini wie so ein duschkopf halt nur klein mit so einem schlauch dran um sich mal kurz was abzubremsen also
das ist.
Drei d druck aufsätze für flaschen.
Ok
Und dann schüttelst dann schüttelst du deine selter flasche oder wie ist das gedacht.
Nein du drehst die flasche um und drückst.
Neben einer glasflasche glaube ich nicht.
Also wie ist es gedacht mit der flasche das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ja warte ich ich suche den link raus.
So eine art.
Gerade auf der webseite von bosp da die haben auch so eine so eine travel and travel be das ist genauso ein flaschen.
To go.
Konzept to go siehst du mal.
Oha,
also mit dieser ganzen klo geschichte die japaner du hast ja schon erwähnt liebe sie gehen ja total steil aber das ist habe ich jetzt auch schon öfter gesehen diese diskussion mit vielen leuten mein ja so dann nimmt man halt einfach die duschbrause das geht natürlich nur wenn du die auch schon technisch in der nähe hast also wenn's so zeigen
klo und
dusche weit voneinander entfernt sind kannst du halt mal nicht eben wie fünf meter schlauch verlegen also vielleicht kannst du das aber das müsstest du dann eben auch erstmal tun und es gibt dann auch alle möglichen varianten,
insbesondere und das muss man ja dann auch noch mal bedenken wenn du jetzt so eine gas etagen heizung hast dann ist es ja so mit warmem wasser sowieso so eine sache du drehst das warme wasser aus aber es kann halt dann auch erstmal so dreißig sekunden dauern bis du
warmes wasser bekommst und kann vielleicht auch mal eine minute dauern bis du konstant warmes wasser bekommst also in derselben temperatur,
das mag bei duschen noch ganz gut funktionieren da hat man halt etwas vorlauf und dann ist es halt so aber das hilft dir natürlich jetzt auf dem klo nicht sonderlich weiter und dann gibt's natürlich tatsächlich welche die einfach nur ein kalt wasseranschluss brauchen und durchlauferhitzer haben,
kein scheiß und damit bist du natürlich dann im im sicheren bereich ne,
ist das eigentlich so ein teil wo sich das ding so von hinten aus fährt oder wie ist das gedacht huch.
Ich habe nur bilder gesehen weil
der typ der das getwittert hatte war einer der ersten der so auf seinem twitter-account meinte dass er jetzt für seine vierköpfige familie irgendwie mal klopapier kaufen will und eine halbe stunde schon durch kreuzberg fährt und nicht findet,
und dann irgendwann hat er ganz heimisch getwittert dass er jetzt so ein teil in der hand hält ich weiß allerdings nicht ob das wird dann auch eine glückliche installation und ein glückliches.
Steht hier auf der webseite okay das ist ja wahrscheinlich das ding mit,
meine güte spray clean.
Ich glaube das sind mir jetzt langsam zu viele details.
Dinge die man nie wissen wollte ist natürlich also designtechnisch ist das ding auf jeden fall schon mal ein fehler also sowas ich irgendwie als klo anzuhängen das ist ja da muss man schon wirklich verzichten aber.
Ja wie gesagt also ich wollte das jetzt auch nicht als die lösung tcm anpreisen aber ich fand's es war so ein interessantes ein interessanter tweet oder ein interessantes ding was in diesem ganzen toilettenpapier drama so an mir vorbei scrollt.
Das ist ein guter punkt irgendwie und auf klopapier zu verzichten meine viele leute sind ja dann das ist ja dann besonders dramatisch dazu übergegangen diese unsäglichen feuchttücher zu benutzen
hallo
das erzeugt dann wieder das nächste problem da gab es auch glaube ich eine gemeinde in bayern oder so mit einem schwer zu merken dann relativ langen namen
das hat bestimmt gleich jemand im slack herausgefunden,
wo die das wasserwerk schon mal das problem hatte dass sie ohnehin erstmal mit dem erhöhten spüli aufkommen nicht klar kam weil ja jetzt alle im homeoffice sind und von daher doppelt so viel kacken wie sonst,
normalerweise sind sie immer irgendwo anders hin gefahren genau ja home kacke ist killing so wasserwerk.
Achtung sendetitel sendung titel.
Und,
also damit halten sie immer schon schwer zu kämpfen aber weil die leute dann auch kein klopapier hatten haben sie dann eben diese diese diese feuchttücher benutzt die halt einfach überhaupt nicht dafür geeignet
sich aufzulösen in diesem normalen wasseraufbereitung prozess und damit war dann natürlich dann auch diese pumpen,
in diesem ganzen prozess sind am laufenden meter verstopft und mussten dann deutlich häufiger gereinigt werden als normalerweise der fall war
also auch da haben wir wieder ganz interessante auswirkungen auf unser doch recht fragile infrastruktur die an der stelle einfach noch gestellt gehört.
Ja und da haben wir noch gar nicht überwinden gesprochen.
Überwindung wieso was ist.
Das ist doch so der infrastruktur feind nummer eins.
Ach so na ja gut.
Übrigens auch da gibt's schon dabei klopapier sind der run auf irgendwelche monitore und zeugs er hat jetzt auch extrem zugenommen,
weil halt viele leute jetzt überhaupt zum ersten mal in dieser situation sind homeoffice machen zu
dürfen nein nicht nur zu dürfen sondern auch zu müssen
und dann feststellen ja die firma zwar schon immer ein laptop mir gegeben aber es steckt normalerweise immer docking-station in der firma und wenn ich die jetzt mit nach hause nehmen ist die glotze vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu klein und da wird da wurde in etlichen firmen wo ich so über drei ecken
keine ahnung verbindung zu habe oder von meinen kunden deren kunden und so die da ging's auch ziemlich ab,
wie die auch ihre infrastruktur umgebaut haben ich weiß zum beispiel dass bestimmte kritisch buden ich sag jetzt mal eine so ein grass versorger zum beispiel,
die sind hingegangen und haben radikal erstmal so zwei etagen von leuten rausgeschmissen also nicht entlassen sondern hier hast du jetzt den laptop vpn zugang geh mal geh mal heim.
Ein gras versorger ein gasversorgung.
Gras versorger braucht keinen externen moni.
Dann sind wir hingegangen haben diese büros alle ausgeräumt und
betten reingestellt und so weiter und so fort weil die sagt wir müssen hier bestimmten betrieb aufrechterhalten sonst fangen die leute noch an zu frieren im märz und haben dann bestimmtes team was sozusagen ihre betriebssteuerung macht dort einquartiert,
also büros geräumt leute mit scheiß nach hause geschickt haben dabei auch erstmal festgestellt dass er gegen so banale probleme stoßen wie
unsere super teure firewall hatten lizenz thema mit vpn zugängen von außen h ja wir haben irgendwie,
fünfhundert mitarbeiter aber unsere lizenz kann los dreihundert und so auch so sachen die sind jetzt alle kleinigkeiten aber jetzt
dieser home-office migrieren ins home-office hat schon manchmal ganz ganz witzige sachen gezeitigt und
aber wie gesagt bis dahin extrem dass die halt eben soll ihre leute ein kaserniert haben damit mit feldberg
und tralala gesagt nee wir ja wir wir wir quarantäne aber wir kannten die hier in der in der firma damit du weiter die gasversorgung bestimmten landesteilen am leben erhält.
Ich habe auch schon gehört dass ich mir jetzt gerade bin ich ganz quellen fest,
kann österreich gewesen sein dass sie für so einen kritischen bereich und ich glaube es war in dem fall die wasserversorgung ein noten team schon mal karate-do haben die alle gesund waren,
das sozusagen vorgehalten wird aber gerade nicht mitarbeitet für den fall dass die sie gerade arbeiten dass da sich der virus ausbricht die alle karate-do werden müssen dass sie dann sozusagen das,
vor garantin vierte team dann quasi übernimmt.
Das versuchen so ein teil zum teil in kliniken auch mit medizinischen personal,
das ist glaube ich auch einer der gründe warum man jetzt die die studenten so ein bisschen schon,
schont an manchen stellen damit die nicht gleich in den wgs und in der vorlesung selber spritzen sondern dass die als nachwuchs also bereit stehen könnten.
Was was heißt die wetten geschont inwiefern wenn die geschont.
Die werden grade nicht aktiv eingesetzt zum beispiel also an manchen an manchen klinik das ist halt klinik intern manche sagen halt studenten dürfen und andere sagen studenten müssen und manche sagen nee studenten erstmal nicht es sei denn,
wir ziehen euch ran.
Übrigens auch unser hauptfeind von vielen gerne immer
ich bin jetzt eh schon verschrieben als als telekom verteidiger aber ich habe ja mit denen berufliche auch so ein bisschen zu tun die sind schon seit
keine ahnung meine kontaktpunkte war zur peeling angeht also die sozusagen backbord telekom backbord am leben erhalten die sind schon seit februar im home-office,
ordentlich verteilt weil sie auch sagt hey wir gucken erstmal dass wir das alle zurzeit solange die panik noch nicht ausgebrochen ist stehen wir mal die leute nach hause und gucken ob die alle ordentlich arbeiten können und so,
sagen dann auch um infektionskrankheiten sowas zu vermeiden aber die die steuern das netz jetzt also,
jetzt nicht das komplette telekomnetz aber so die leute die halt so die fetten internet backgrounds machen also was die sind schon eine ganze weile zuhause nicht erst seit letzter woche haben sie auch gut nachgedacht.
Ist ja interessant dass jetzt glaube ich der der punkt mit ist internet eigentlich eine kritische infrastruktur das ist jetzt glaube ich durch ne also meine uns ist glaube ich allen klar hätten wir jetzt diese situation vor zehn jahren gehabt,
das wäre nicht so lustig also,
die möglichkeiten die jetzt bestehen über videokonferenz gegenüber internet et cetera überhaupt noch miteinander in kontakt zu bleiben und zum großen teil vielleicht eben auch wirtschaftliche beziehungen fortzuführen das ist natürlich,
schon ein ein großer vorteil so wie es heute ist trotzdem ist es natürlich nicht optimal und da bin ich auch ganz gerne von dir nochmal clemens was hören,
weil ich denke es jetzt auch der zeitpunkt gekommen mal ein paar tipps auszupacken für homeoffice design,
und da gibt es natürlich jetzt die verschiedensten aspekte und blickwinkel die man einnehmen kann oder ausgraben kann,
wo du jetzt gerade telekom schon mal angesprochen hast wie schätzt du denn die,
grundfeste zeit eigentlich der internetversorgung deutschland ein derzeit.
Die ist eigentlich ganz gut
es gibt an netz grenzen immer wieder so probleme dort habe ich jetzt gerade zu spüren gekriegt wir benutzen jetzt hier auch c c hatte ja schon mal hat es ja vorhin schon gesagt mal angeteasert kann man vielleicht nochmal drauf die details
und ich habe das auch organisiert für ein paar leute so im berliner umfeld da da war zu machen und hab dann festgestellt
das verkehrs beziehungen die normalerweise irrelevant sind nämlich von heim anschluss
person a zu heimatschutz person b jetzt natürlich massiv benutzt werden weil die leute jetzt alle telefon oder videokonferenzen machen.
Und natürlich jetzt
eben jemand hinter dem kabel deutschland anschluss mit jemandem am telekom anschluss jetzt mal videografieren will das passiert normalerweise ja nicht wenn die jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie,
gegenseitige downloads oder ja da passiert nicht so viel wie jetzt
und da darf jetzt teilweise wirklich noch so ein bisschen am peeling ich habe jetzt zum beispiel gerade was kabel deutschland angeht in berlin die situation festgestellt dass von denen zu unserem server geht der verkehr der auch
in berlin steht wir stehen hängen beide am bcs also sozusagen wir haben beide sowohl kabel deutschland als auch
mein ding dort hängen an einem internet nichtsdestotrotz geht der verkehr von kabel deutschland einmal über die schweizer kommt über amsterdam zurück,
und da hab ich dir denn angeschrieben hab dann sagt so leute das ist ja ein bisschen semi-optimal ihr müsst eigentlich nur eine config ändern du musst jetzt keiner rausgehen auch nur ein halbes kabel stecken oder sonst irgendwas und die so nö wir haben jetzt gerade andere sachen zu tun.
Okay kann ich verstehen klar die müssen jetzt ein bundesweites kabelnetz da am leben erhalten und hin und her aber das sind so sachen die normalerweise kein interessieren weil normalerweise hast du ja immer diese,
down ja deswegen ist ja auch in deutschland immer noch so so beliebt diese,
diese spaltung ablenken und down link diese diskussion die wir schon hundertmal hatten über symmetrische internetanschlüsse zuhause wo sie immer alle sagten hey wieso die leute gucken halt netflix oder konsumieren halt die brauchen halt nur ein down link der so und so breit ist
brauchen halt nur einen ablenkt der sohn so breites war sie eigentlich nicht nicht nichts selber abladen diese situation das ändert sich jetzt gerade radikal,
also durch diese und wenn halt jetzt irgendwo in welche videokonferenzen ruckeln zwischen leuten liegt genau an solchen peeling themen oder dass der ablenken zu schmal ist das liegt nicht daran dass der backboard zu schwach ist.
Oder die back bones von den großen providern
deswegen finde ich auch zum beispiel solche sachen wie wir wir drängen jetzt mal netflix dass er mal fünfundzwanzig prozent weniger bandbreite ausstreut finde ich es,
komplett mega affig das ist einfach
populismus oder sagen wir mal ist es merkt befreites aktionismus tum der auch von der eu runtertropft
und jeder ordentliche hat sich auch ordentlich darüber aufgeregt also es gibt ja leute die schon seit jahren zum beispiel die netflix cash server in ihrem netz haben um genau eben nicht diese situation zu haben und jetzt kommt jemand von der eu und klingelt bei,
netflix an und sagt dreht doch mal die bandbreite runter weil sonst bei uns die videokonferenzen ruckeln dit ist wirklich einfach da ist einfach schlechtes netz design,
perlt jetzt mal an die party jetzt mal nach oben.
Wie ist denn das überhaupt gelaufen also wer hat denn da wen gebeten das war also keine entscheidung von netflix selber sondern die sind dazu gedrängt worden.
Ja nicht gedrängt die sind angefragt worden also die leute haben halt festgestellt als das losging das hat bestimmte videokonferenz konstellation gibt die ruckeln so und da gibt es natürlich
tausend und drei gründer das kann zum beispiel sein dass jetzt alle leute plötzlich um webtext drauf gesprungen sind und cisco damit nicht gerechnet hat dass das passiert und das ist einfach bei denen auf dem server ruckelt und alle möglichen gründe die kann man ja auch mal untersuchen aber irgendjemand meinte denn ja ja der netflix der braucht so viel bandbreite und dann ist irgendein aktionismus
in brüssel auf auf auf die bühne gesprungen hat gesagt oh das ist aber ganz schlimm schlimm schlimm jetzt jetzt fragen wir doch mal den netflix und natürlich auch den amazon für seinen amazon prime
nicht in disney übrigens aber egal wie das fragen wir jetzt mal so die große streaming anbieter achso den google auch für seinen youtube
und dann bei google auch angerufen und habe gesagt könnte mich ein bisschen weniger streamen
und wenn man sich so ein bisschen in dieser szene rumtreibt und einfach weiß wie die angeschlossen sind netflix und google und amazon gehören zu den leuten die mit jedem pier in den ich bei drei auf den bäumen ist
ernsthaft also da muss man nicht mal betteln oder sonst was du gehst du halt an irgendein six wo jeder
provider sein sollte und davon haben wir reichlich steckst leider in israel rein und sagst hallo google hallo amazon hallo netflix kannst du nicht machen ich meine ich betreibe ein ganz kleines für diese geschichte die wir dort oben auf dem turm haben und ich mit dem popel provider.
Erkläre kurz mal erklären.
Autonomes system ein eis also eine der also in seiner seiner.
Also du bist sozusagen wie ein internetservice-provider.
Ich bin ein internet service.
Du bist ein du bist ein internetservice-provider aber du hast jetzt nicht tausend kunden oder so sondern du hast weniger paar dutzend genau.
Nichtsdestotrotz es gibt ja da diese situation dass man sagt das geil oder ganz früher als das internet mal erschaffen wurde hat sich jeder mit jedem einzeln verbunden
diese zeiten sind lange vorbei heute macht man net so dass man sich an so einem internet x change points trifft an x davon gibt's commercial
x die heißen six deswegen commercial internet exchange point sowas gibt's auch noch mal in nicht kommerziell in berlin hat die glaub ich schon mal erwähnt gibt's zum beispiel auch den community ex- so für alle leute die was machen was nicht kommerziell ist aber mal ordentlich blitz brauchen wo man sich so anhängen kann mit seinem zeugs
und wir haben in berlin sonst noch zwei six nämlich den bcs in berlin commercial internet und den ethics,
daran teilzunehmen ist kostet kein großes geld schon gar nicht für einen größeren eis also wir reden hier über dreistellige zahlen
du musst halt da dein equipment oder deine leitung zu diesem ort hin haben da gibt es in berlin ein dutzend rechenzentren wo man sich da anstecken kann
und dann tut man da einen dreistelligen betrag oder einen kleineren vierstelligen betrag wenn man es wirklich ernst wissen ernsthaft wissen will auf den tisch und dann kann man mit all diesen leuten reden man ist dann direkt verbunden mit google mit apple mit microsoft mit amazon mit,
cloud flair mit trallala den ganzen die ganzen freaks alle die da sind facebook sogar und so.
Nur mit der telekom nicht.
Die telekom spielt da nicht mit nein,
aber wie man sieht kabel deutschland spielt auch nicht mit also wir müssen jetzt nicht auf der telekom rumhacken nur es gibt so ein paar andere leute die sich für für so groß halten dass sie das nicht nötig haben,
telekom ja ich geb's mal ganz ehrlich zu wir kaufen uns einfach einen link ein wir haben einen guten deal mit den,
da funktioniert es ist zwar politisch moralisch ärgerlich dass wir dafür bezahlen müssen für den verkehr den ihre kunden ihn schon mal bezahlen
aber technische sind funktioniert eins a deswegen hat mit telekom überhaupt gar kein problem ich habe halt probleme mit
diesen leuten die sich diese möchte gern groß buden die sich auch so gegenseitig zusammen gekauft haben in meinem muss ja mal angucken kabel deutschland
gehört wie eins nee nicht eins und eins und eins versatel aber kabel deutschland,
vodafone und vodafone hat sich jetzt cable irgendwie oder nicht oder eingekauft also das ist ein kompletter zoo von peeling und von routine war da stattfindet das macht keinen spaß,
wer übrigens auch pierre tiere sogar mit telefonica schimpfe immer auf tour oder so aber mit telefonica auch in berlin das heißt also auch der verkehr ist eigentlich auch alles easy peasy
und normalerweise gesagt
du kommst eben sehr sehr günstig an die großen content provider ran wenn du jetzt sagst oh ich habe aber so viele kunden die bei netflix sind da sagt der netflix erst zu nena bier noch hier mit uns hier für oma kannst du haben,
wenn es ganz schlimm haben willst stehen ja solche boden wie netflix aber andere jetzt auch.
Sogenannte cash sauber zur verfügung das heißt du kannst dann hingehen und in deinem netz in irgendein rechenzentrum schmeißt du denn so eine kiste rein von netflix die die dafür sorgt dass sie jetzt nicht jeden content jede filmchen einzeln von denen über dein teurer,
ziehen mussten so jetzt ist alles schon da und seit jahren es hat mit corona nix zu tun das ist jetzt alles schon da und wenn also jetzt heutzutage noch jemand kommt
und sagt oh aber da haben wir jetzt fünf leute stream jetzt gerade was per netflix und deswegen rocken hier die videokonferenzen dann haben sie echt den schuss nicht gehört und jetzt sind nicht viele das passiert mit dem telekomnetz nicht das passiert mir auch in anderen letztendlich bei meinem einen mini,
passiert es auch nicht und ich finde es halt einfach dann blöde wenn so die diese sparbrötchen die da sind,
und das netz immer so spitz auf knopf mit ganz wenig engineering mit ganz wenig aufwand versuchen zusammen zu klöppeln jetzt hingehen und bei der eu betteln dass man ihn netflix bitte runterdrehen möchte,
das finde ich halt so ein bisschen so ja toll alle anderen bauen ihr netz ordentlichen du tust es nicht und deswegen dürfen wir anderen jetzt alle kinder auf,
felix pixel matsch sehen ist ja nicht so netflix code ja so gut und merkst eigentlich komm den unterschied aber
trotzdem ich fand das halt so ein bisschen so was das jetzt für den aktien ist wir haben jetzt tausend andere sachen die wir zu erledigen haben man könnte zum beispiel mal der investitionsbank
berlin brandenburg mal eine ordentliche webseite hintun oder überhaupt mal den ganzen staatlichen steht.
Stattdessen stattdessen betteln wir jetzt amerikanische konzerne an sie möchten uns doch bitte nicht im internet mit pixeln fluten das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen so ach.
Hat denn jemand von euch den kampf da versucht aufzunehmen mit der i g b also hintergrund ist dass da ja jetzt gerade eine webseite freigeschaltet wurde,
oder zumindest haben sie das behauptet wo man beantragen kann glaube ich dass man erstmal diese fünftausend euro darlehen später nicht zurückgezahlt werden müssen bekommen kann dann sehe ich das richtig ich habe.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht aber ich kenne leute die das gemacht haben das ist wirklich ist wirklich echt absurd war die da getrieben haben und zwar auch nicht nur,
nicht nur das jetzt da das beantragen kannst oder du kannst jetzt erstmal eine elektronische wartennummer ziehen,
und dann wenn du die hast dann hast du keine ahnung fünfunddreißig minuten zeit um auf der webseite irgendwas zu klicken,
weiß aber nicht wie das aussieht weil wie gesagt ich habe das nicht gemacht und ist auch noch unbekannt ob das irgendwie funktioniert aber du kannst jetzt überhaupt erstmal nur eine wartenummer ziehen pass auf jetzt kommt.
Die warteschlange ist so hundertfünfzigtausend leute lang.
Pass auf jetzt der server der nur die warte nummern vergibt den fahren sie abends runter bald jetzt elektronische wartezimmer vergabe das ist ein rechner der der darf aus arbeitsschutz- finden keine ahnung nach zweiundzwanzig uhr nicht mehr funktionieren und am wochenende sowieso nicht.
Klar kannst du nicht einfach nachts ne warte nummer zehn clemens denkst du denn hin nachts kannst ja auch sonst nicht.
Komplett ist so komplett absurd das hat auch mit soforthilfe nichts zu tun ich meine da kann jetzt muss jetzt nicht auf die schimpfen ist halt eine kleine eine kleine bank die was ich so ein bisschen fördertöpfe verwaltet sonst die ist nicht dafür ausgestattet.
Ja aber ich bitte,
die leute sollen ein formular ausfüllen da hat sich hat sie auch auf twitter auch schon höchst erregt ne ein formular ausfüllen im jahr zwanzig zwanzig was erlauben.
Und bitte wieder rüberfaxen ausdrucken und rüberfaxen.
Ja also das ist auch wirklich ich meine das ist das einzige was neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig im web überhaupt funktioniert hat neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig fünfundzwanzig jahre her.
Es ist auch kein problem irgendwie ein formular bereitzustellen wenn man einigermaßen hirn hat und halt nicht bank it-ler ist oder sonst irgendwas sorry für die zuhörenden bank aber ihr seid echt verschrieben,
aus gründen der jemals in so eine bank reingeguckt hat weiß wovon ich rede,
also jetzt ja aber jetzt nochmal hinzugehen jetzt einfach sich irgendwo eine scheiße seite zu klicken beim amazon meinetwegen und da der drecks formular zu hinterlegen oder als google doch irgendwo bei hinzustellen,
nein nein du darfst jetzt warte nummern ziehen.
Oder so eine next cloud.
Bis zweiundzwanzig uhr darfst du warte nummern ziehen und dann darfst du hast du fünfunddreißig minuten zeit wenn deine warte nummer dran ist um dann,
diese formular runterzuladen oder.
Formular hätte auch als pdf wunderbar funktioniert füllt man aus schickt man irgendwohin per mail wäre auch alles wunderbar also aber ich meine was das ja eigentlich zeigt und das ist vielleicht dann das nächste interessante thema,
deutschland und das internet ja ich bin da ja schon immer sehr skeptisch gewesen.
Das muss gar nicht internet sein es reicht schon wenn du ein computer dran.
Naja okay ich gehe sagen wir mal weiter also deutschland und informationsverarbeitung,
digitale ich weiß nicht ganz genau wo ich die grenze ziehen soll weil es gibt ja bestimmte dinge die kann deutschland an sich ganz gut,
elektrik geht ganz gut elektronik geht eigentlich auch ganz gut aber alles was nach elektronik kommt das wird schwierig.
Wasser kommt aus der steckdose.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Animierte blinker.
Ja ich ich weiß nicht was,
also ich bin mir nicht wirklich sicher ob ich vollständig verstanden habe was das problem ist ich weiß nur es gibt eins und es ist irgendwo eine,
eine eine eine mischung aus angst und,
so einer könnt ihr das irgendwie besser greifen vielleicht mal hier die jüngere abteilung weil ich irgendwie nicht verstehe warum sich das auch nicht ändert also weil.
Die jüngere abteilung fange ich würde die wird deine eltern fragen oder meine.
Nee nee aber diese die aber sind die noch das problem es muss sich doch irgendwann mal ändern,
ich denke halt dass das dass das kulturmanagment ist ich glaube das ist ein kulturelles problem ist und und nicht ein reines generationsprojekt dass dass da irgendwas in unserer gesellschaft generell schief läuft
vielleicht ist es auch so ein so ein so ein sättigungseffekt,
irgendwie uns ging schon zu gut wir müssen uns jetzt auch nichts mehr einstellen aber eigentlich was mir so fehlt ist so ein bisschen so eine gewisse wie formuliere ich denn das,
so eine art.
Gesunder menschenverstand.
Nein,
eine es es fehlt es fehlt an eine affinität es fehlt einfach an einem,
an einer einer einer einer freude daran da mit zu experimentieren und das mal gerne auszuprobieren guck dir jetzt an.
Einem windows user verdenken.
Wozu braucht man das.
Das markenteil.
Tim ich kann da glaube ich mal was dazu sagen
das ganze problem mit dieser also ich habe mal ein projekt für einen verein ministerium gemacht das problem ist halt die haben eine überlastete it zu meistens die sich auch noch aus versehen um diese webseiten kümmern müssen und
die haben mit ihren eigentlichen kernprobleme schon so viel zu tun dass sie nie dazukommen
sagen wir mal nur das neu zu machen wenn du denen aber halt auch noch sagst hey macht das mein friendly und was weiß ich noch tralala und schön sind die,
komplett überfordert wenn du dann aber mal hinkommst also es war halt so ein kleineres projekt was wir gemacht haben,
da haben wir vor allem so we design user experience in den vordergrund gestellt ehrlich ich habe noch nie so ein dankbaren kunden gehabt aber die sind in der regel die haben kein geld eigentlich für sowas und das ist das.
Ja die machen sich aber auch viel probleme sehr.
Die sind sowas von.
Machen sich wirklich sehr sehr viel.
Klar aber die sind sowas von happy und dankbar wenn leute mit ideen zu den kommen.
Du kannst doch nicht sagen deutschland kommt im internet nicht vorbei weil deutschland kein geld hat ich meine wenn einer geld hat dann ist es doch wohl deutschland.
Ja aber dann gibt es
die nächste ebene wenn du so konzerne wie die deutsche bahn oder sowas also ich habe ja wie hatte ich ja auch glaube ich schon mal erzählt hier in meiner kurzen berater tätigkeit habe ich ja ein paar firmen mal von innen gesehen und die haben halt alle
fünf bis sechs so eine berater boden drin die sich um ihre it-projekte kümmern die alle ihr eigenes schnitzel in den in die flamme halten wollen oder steak besser gesagt,
die anderen steaks vom stückchen schubsen von der anderen bude und die haben ja selber meistens gar nicht so viel eigene it-party aber ja also die bahn hat
ungefähr jedes beratungsunternehmen auf dieser erde unter vertrag die alle irgendwelche kleinen teilprojekte machen die alle,
viel geld fressen nie fertig werden und wenn sie fertig werden scheiße sind also geld gibt's das wird da einfach verbrannt so mit beiden händen.
Aber ist das ursache oder ist das nicht auch schon symptom weil ich denke dass es das ist schon eher ein symptom weil.
Es ist beides.
Ja wahrscheinlich also es ist so dieses wir wollen uns nicht selber aktiv darum kümmern deswegen holen wir uns so externe leute rein weil wir haben davon ja keine ahnung aber irgendwie müssen wir das irgendwie machen
anstatt einfach zu dieses aktive geil internet möglichkeiten und chancen da
fokussieren wir uns jetzt drauf wir versuchen herauszufinden was diese möglichkeiten
uns bieten um uns als unternehmen behörde struktur organisation was auch immer man man macht das zu machen stattdessen wird es als belastung angesehen stattdessen ist irgendwie eine bedrohung von außen die dann eben in solchen strukturen mündet
und und ich finde halt auf dieses ich versuche zu verstehen was ist die die blockade im hirn,
das nicht von vornherein andere strukturen angestrebt werden das begreife ich.
Wozu denn faxgerät funktionieren doch ich weiß gar nicht was.
Geräte funktioniert auch ich meine da haben wir ja schon die sache allein mit den corona melde zahlen die halt teilweise nicht durchkam weil fax nummer belegt das ist einfach echt zwanzig zwanzig.
Ich hatte auch bei so einer bank da mal eine zeit lang gesessen und die haben ganz verzweifelt versucht so jetzt wir machen auch so start-up und wir machen alles richtig und wir machen alles hip und,
die haben einfach extreme probleme so mit ihrem banken image überhaupt irgendwie coole leute zu engagieren und dann haben sie sich so richtig viel mühe gegeben.
Und haben das dann man sogar so verzweifelt dass die während die leute noch in der probezeit waren schon mit so einem vertrag nochmal zum arbeitsplatz gegangen sind und so,
sag mal willst du dich nicht vielleicht jetzt schon committen so für so richtig also nicht dass er dann wieder weg gehst und so weiter den sind halt also die hätten zum beispiel massiv probleme überhaupt leute zu finden das like aber
zum teil würde ich darin also würde ich sagen daran dass,
in der bank da gibt's so ein paar leute die wollen coole sachen machen die haben auch ein bisschen ahnung und so weiter aber dann gibt's da halt auch so einen riesigen strom von leuten ja aber wir haben es doch schon immer so gemacht und,
ausbremsen runterkühlen und dann hauen die ganzen coolen leute wieder ab weil sie merken so richtig was geht hier doch nicht weil da diese ganzen bremse an den schaltern,
und das ist halt so diese feedback-schleife also es gibt immer mal in diesem unternehmen auch leute die wirklich wo du denkst ja wenn man die jetzt einfach machen lassen würde,
dann würde alles gut werden aber dann kommt irgendwie durch irgendeinen,
bremse rein sondern langsamer so einer der alles so machen will wie immer und dann,
tante auch alle anderen ab die was reißen wollen oder bezahlens beziehungsweise wir gehen dann woanders hin und dann haben sie keine eigenen leute dann kaufen sich beratungsfirma ein,
verbrennen unmengen geld und.
Die sind übrigens noch schlimmer da haben wir wirklich ein aber das ist jetzt kein corona spezifisches sondern das ist halt ein ganz,
problem an dem wir schon sehr sehr lange kranken,
also auch gerade diese geschichte wie ich mache ja gelegentlich noch consulting für so leute die interessante projekte haben den sage ich auch gleich von vorneweg so beim beim vorstellen so sagt pass mal auf,
ihr wollt dass hier was ändert und deswegen habt ihr mich auch angefragt und ich hätte auch spaß daran aber erst dann wenn ich höre das haben wir ja noch nie so gemacht oder das haben wir schon immer so und so gemacht,
dann zeigt er matches dann könnt ihr euch auch gleich mal da könnt ihr euch ein standard consultant mit schlips leisten der ist zwar teurer aber
dafür einen schlips offensichtlich wichtig und dann macht es doch so
aber das ist wirklich ein ist ein echtes problem dieses diese eingefahrene also wenn ich daran denke meine kunden müssen ja teilweise mit deren kunden so sachen machen und dann werden mal so v p n verbindungen geschaltet
und das ist nicht so man wirft sich einfach mal parameter an kopf so über telefon und
also ich brauche dreißig sekunden umso ding einzurichten nein da werden dann formulare ausgetauscht,
dann dauert die firewall freischaltung auf der gegenseite nochmal drei monate und ist jetzt keine übertreibung.
Muss ja alles nach op funktionieren.
So sehen die standardprozedere immer immer immer immer immer wieder und dann denkst du auch so super dann könnte ich bücher drüber schreiben über diese diese welt ist wirklich echte sind horror romane.
Aber ich würde ja denken nach wie vor und immer wieder ist das so ein grundlagenthema also in dem moment wo man mal in der schule
bildung und so weiter so internet und computer als first class drin hätte und den leuten sagt wie die dinge funktionieren damit irgendwie die sich nicht
ich weiß nicht irgendwas erzählen lassen müssen von sogenannten computer spezialisten oder was auch immer
in dem moment würde sich das glaube ich deutlich besser dann hätten die leute glaube ich auch mehr mut dinge selber zu machen statt immer gleich irgendwie zu fragen ja wer kann mir das problem lösen oder wie kriege ich das jetzt hin,
weil vieles ist ja gar nicht so schwer aber wie gesagt ich mache ja seit elf jahren oder zwölf mittlerweile sogar diesen kurs da in der uni und es ist,
letztens wurde ich gefragt ob sich in den zwölf jahren etwas geändert hat und dann musste ich auch ganz nüchtern feststellen eigentlich nicht die fragen sind immer noch die gleichen die leute haben immer noch nicht in der schule im gymnasium in der uni irgendwas von internet oder computer gelernt,
es ist halt irgendwie so lange sich das nicht ändert glaube ich ändert sich der rest nicht.
Irgendeine obskure programmiersprache in der schule gelernt die keine sau braucht.
Ja
In der schule gelernt.
Das pascal der heutigen zeit heißt java rainer meinte auch gerade im chat soja behörden kontext so kann man das nicht auch alles im januar machen also es ist einfach dieses land ist einfach hinterher und es ist einfach nicht,
also dass man rückständig ist damit kann ich ja irgendwie noch leben aber dass man rückständig bleiben will das finde ich halt wirklich kriminell also.
Die leute haben doch gerade erst kennengelernt dass es sowas wie java gibt und die sind halt einfach ein bisschen hinterher und für die ist dann das.
Gott java.
Tim da ist das nächste problem dass die meisten halt auch einfach gar nicht überhaupt schon mal die sonne gesehen haben ich habe da so ein schönes buch über ästhetik und da ist irgendwie eines der ersten sätze jemand der noch nie ein sauberes glas gesehen hat denkt das schmutzige gläser das geilste auf der welt sind
und wenn du diese ganzen firmen reinguckst,
firmen reinguckst die haben halt noch nie gesehen wie moderne softwareentwicklung geht oder modernes projektmanagement die machen das immer noch so wie.
Oder netzwerk.
Kaufmannsladen oder weiß nicht so geführt haben geführt hat und ich dachte halt als ich hier bei vouga damals gearbeitet hat die hatten ja nicht nur die bücher gekauft sondern auch gelesen und auch noch umgesetzt,
da dachte ich so ist startup und so ist das in jeder modernen firma und dann als ich diesen beraterjob da jetzt ein paar jahre gemacht hab guckst in die firmen rein denkst du ja die haben vielleicht die bücher manchmal noch im schrank gelesen haben es die wenigsten und umgesetzt wird davon nüscht und,
solange die nicht gesehen haben dass es auch überhaupt funktionieren kann traut sich auch keiner dass man umzusetzen das ist auch so ein.
Also ja war es ist wirklich ein guter vergleich finde ich mit mit dem aktuellen zustand weil mein sohn mein sohn ist gerade dabei irgendwelche minecraft mods zu hacken man hat dann tatsächlich irgendwie sich in der clips hochgezogen und irgendwie
dann auf einmal zuhause in ja war dann irgendwie hier fehler und.
Aber der mindcraft java code ist so schön.
Ist er das auf jeden fall ja war es
ja bei java ist noch furchtbar dann gucke ich da so drauf und was denn hier so dass der fehler ist dann muss ich dann erstmal so mein begrenztes jahr war wissen irgendwie aus dem aus der hintersten rinde meines hirsches rauskratzen und starre dann auf diese variablen deklaration entsteht da
public static finale.
Natalia erinnern wir uns.
Dann recherchierst du das erstmal bist du begreifst was das ist dass es einfach nichts anderes ist als irgendwie eine öffentliche konstante und,
was für ein aufwand nur um so eine scheiß konstante zu beschreiben man hätte ja auch einfach konstant schreiben können nein public tätig und das ist genau die richtige bezeichnung für für unser system wo wir das einfach public,
es ist total static feine wieder ändert sich nix mehr.
Für eine sendung.
Ja
Finale.
Ja also es gibt auf jeden fall kleine gallische dörfer wo irgendwie der der nektar der honig nektar und auch der vegane nektar wie auch immer,
der agaven.
Oder angaben dicksaft liest ja.
Nicht alles hoffnungslos gerade die leute an den hörgeräten die denken wieso diese die war doch genauso immer schon so scheiße wie ihr es gerade beschreibt nein nein nein es geht anders glaubt mir
es ist nur schwer diese orte zu finden also auf jeden fall findet man sie nicht bei großkonzernen das ist schon mal so 'ne goldene regel.
Großkonzerne sind ja das eine der ganze staat ist das andere ich meine wir haben halt jetzt irgendwie immer noch so ein so ein staat der einfach digitale infrastruktur nicht ins zentrum seine aktivitäten stellt obwohl nichts mehr laufen würde in diesem scheiß laden soll ich meine ich habe
auf der straße jemanden getroffen der arbeitet im bundestag und er hat dann irgendwie auch,
der hat irgendwie so weiße gleiche kinder in der in der klasse da lernt man sich so ein bisschen irgendwie anders kennen auch nur so das wäre irgendwie totale
katastrophe dass ich jetzt halt einfach alle überhaupt nicht mehr wissen wie sie miteinander zusammenarbeiten dürfen weil sie auf der einen seite das auch alles nicht benutzen dürfen und natürlich auch die security implikationen davon
von dieser ganzen home-office situation vollkommen unklar ist,
es wird dich einfach es wird einfach zeit dass wir jetzt aufwachen und das irgendwie ein internet ministerium gibt und dass dass das einfach digital ist genauso aufgestellt ist wie finanziell ist.
Ja das sind auch so behandelt wird wie kabelfernsehen mindestens sowie kabelfernsehen bitte also mit derselben.
Das ging schnell damals mit karl.
Das ging relativ schnell da wurde auch nicht diskutiert ob die straße aufgerissen wird oder ob das millionen kostet oder wie auch immer.
Da wurde einfach gemacht und dann kann ich auch noch erinnern so an fällen wo man irgendein blöder böser bagger mal so ein kabel ausgegraben hat,
da war aber was los also in berlin gibt's ja für die berliner die oder die gibt's ja diese schöne lange heerstraße und er läuft auch so ein kabel danke und am ende dieser herde am westlichen ende dieser heerstraße so ein großer und wohngebiet,
so trabantensiedlung und so westberlin noch und da hat jemand mal so auf der heerstraße mal dieses kabelfernsehen feed kabel da mal ausgebuddelt
und die leute die waren echt das fred die haben die haben den notruf angerufen bei polizei und feuerwehr weise zur störungsstelle nicht mehr durchkam weil natürlich jeder hannes und sein bruder bei der störungsstelle angerufen hat weil das fernsehen ja nicht ging.
Und dann haben sie in ihrer peine angerufen notrufe angerufen und so also das da haben wir mal sehen was wofür für ein,
hat in der bevölkerung und so aber die diskussion darüber ob jetzt überhaupt kabelfernsehen machen oder nicht die man hat ihn einfach gesagt,
alter da gibt's jetzt noch mehr programme und schon waren die alle still da wartet vollkommen selbstverständlich,
das kabelfernsehen geben muss und das dafür meine straße aufgebuddelt werden muss da gab es keine diskussion also wenigstens
wenigstens auf dem level wert schön wenn man vielleicht im internet eher mal so wie eine straße begreifen würde
auch was so diese ganzen politik und wer darauf fahren und wer zahlt dafür watt und so das kann man ja eher mit so einer straße vergleichen aber so vom gesellschaftlichen verständnis er würde ich's schon würde mir das schon reichen wendet so gesehen wurde wieder
kabelfernsehen in den achtziger und neunziger jahren.
Stroh also straße straße reicht mir nicht weil die können auch mal gesperrt sein wasser strom wasser internet.
Cisco.
Also wenn wir im internet weg ist dann ist das genauso schlimm wie wasser ist weg und es ist genauso schlimm wie strom ist weg.
Scheiße vergessen wenn die scheiße nicht abschließt.
Ja
Ja andi wasser.
Glaube ich auch zu problemen.
Ist aber auch wasser irgendwie also das gehört zu wasser.
Ich würde mal noch ganz kurz einen kleinen buchtipp einstreuen zu diesem soll sich alles mal ändern und besser werden,
und zwar woran ja auch viele organisationen ab einer gewissen größe scheitern ist halt irgendwie noch so ein bissel innovativ und dynamisch zu bleiben und es gibt so ein buch von red dead die ihren,
ihren scaling prozess quasi retrospektive dokumentiert haben wie sie so von ganz klein nach übermäßig groß gewachsen sind und wie sie so ihr momentum da aufrecht erhaltet erhalten haben
das wurde mir auf jeden fall schon vor ein paar leuten auch sehr empfohlen worauf hin ich mir das auch mal gegönnt habe kann ich als inspiration auf jeden fall auch mal,
in die runde ich habe den link in die show in den slack gepostet ich weiß nicht im deutschen amazon gibt's das nicht deswegen ist es ein kommen link,
aber im wesentlichen sei auch dann nur noch gesagt wenn ihr in so firmen arbeitet die so ganz furchtbar sind,
die probleme sind alle schon gelöst es gibt schon zig bücher darüber man muss sie nur lesen und verstehen und anwenden.
Man muss den willen haben was zu ändern.
Es geht auf jeden fall.
Ich würde ganz kurz das thema bücher jacken ich habe nämlich zwei zwei bücher bekommen über die ich mich ganz doll gefreut habe das eine ist von oliver sagt der mann der seine frau mit dem hut verwechselte,
was halt,
neurologische wahrnehmungsstörenden also von einem arzt geschrieben schon in den mitte der achtziger veröffentlicht im prinzip anekdotisch kurzgeschichten über interessante neurologische störungen,
wie halt zum beispiel wahrnehmungsstörenden dass im prinzip im hirn bestimmte areale nicht funktionieren und diese assoziation was gerade gesehen wird,
nicht mit dem was man denkt was gesehen wird kombiniert ist dann passiert es halt zum beispiel dass man personen mit hut ständern verwechselt oder köpfe.
Hallo.
Also ist es halt wirklich ganz interessant und amüsant geschrieben,
ist nicht auf der aktuellen medizinischen also es ist nicht aktuell medizinisch und man muss auch immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein er geht am anfang kurz drauf ein wenn halt ärzte über patienten reden ist es immer irgendwie,
ethisch moralisch teilweise schwierig weil man halt von anderen personen die geschichten erzählt,
aber es ist trotzdem lustig deshalb habe ich mich sehr drüber gefreut,
und das andere ist von robert ford ein auch sehr toller podcaster how to the race ist das ist derzeit mein licht,
für wenn ich fleißig die situation schreibe weil das sehr lustig ist und er eine sehr lustige person und da freue ich mich drauf und deshalb ganz lieben dank.
Moment prokrastinieren du damit.
Nein nein das ist eine belohnung belohnung,
später.
Pro castaño.
Ach so wenn wenn wir gerade bei geschenken und danke sagen sind vielleicht würde ich das auch noch kurz erwähnen ich möchte mich bei nadine bedanken hätte mich letztens mit kaffee versorgt in so schwierigen zeiten besonders gern gesehen.
Gut wollen wir ein neues segment aufmachen bevor wir das thema internet und wie es uns alle retten kann komplett verlassen,
weil wir müssen ja auch noch über apple reden heute auf jeden fall aber wir sollten vielleicht mal ein paar konkrete tipps zusammen fegen,
was man in der aktuellen situation mit dem internet alles für tolle sachen machen kann oder auch gerne.
Klemmer wir haben sie alle schon vor zehn jahren getan.
Ja
Das stimmt sogar wir haben vor zehn jahren studiert.
Vielleicht sind ja auch ein paar neue dazugekommen,
ich würde mal kurz anfangen weil ich glaube die größte nachfrage in den letzten wochen gab's halt erstens was für ein headset soll ich mir kaufen
und mit welcher videokonferenz software kommt man irgendwie vorwärts für welche anwendungen,
und da das ja immer so ein bisschen davon abhängt was man jetzt eigentlich konkret machen will ob man da irgendwie eins zu eins eins zu ende zu ende systeme hat,
und so weiter würde ich euch mal offen lassen ein lösungsmodus moment eurer wahl zu benennen,
wir können auch gerne mit dem gitzi anfangen weil wir das ja gerade in diesem moment verwenden clemens magst du mal was.
Tizi ist eins von sich dinge an ich finde es
ich hab's installiert auf einem der server die wir dort haben in den besagten kleinen weil es sich einfach installieren lässt zumindestens die grundversion davon wenn man also überhaupt erstmal was haben will b.
Sag doch erst mal was es ist clemens.
Ja okay ja so hast du vollkommen recht
gitzi ist eine eine lösung wo man telefon oder die videokonferenzen abhalten kann mit ein bis in den leuten
je nach server stärker auch durchaus gibt auch leute die auch mit hundert leuten mal ausprobiert haben soll auch gehen,
was aus meiner sicht den vorteil hat dass es
unsäglich einfach zu bedienen ist du brauchst nämlich nichts weiter als einen link du musst dich nirgendwo anmelden wie bei zoom oder skype oder webpack wurde erst irgendwelche accounts haben muss wurde in welche daten freischalten muss selbst wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal
gänsefüßchen umsonst ist wir erinnern uns an den standardsatz vierhundert product the product
sondern bei gisi miet reicht es aus wenn man irgendjemand so ein service treibt und es macht inzwischen jeder hannes und sein bruder,
wobei ich jetzt auch so ein dummer bruder bin aber da gibt es jede menge öffentliche server von den linus hat einzulaufen hat,
welche zu laufen es gibt leute die haben inzwischen ein ganzes server formen aufgesetzt
bei hetzer gibt's 'ne das ist ja auch so ein provider relativ billiger in deutschland gibt es inzwischen eine fertige anleitung dafür klickst du hier klickst du da klickst du dort drei minuten später hast du deine eigene server instanz.
Und dann verteilst du nur noch einen link die leute brauchen jetzt nicht notwendigerweise eine spezielle ab
es gibt gründe warum man vielleicht eine haben möchte auf dem telefon oder so aber du kannst einfach denn diese diesen link verteilen die leute brauchen dann einigermaßen modernen browser natürlich aber klicken denn da drauf und das ist es und du musst dich nicht anmelden da wird
gelockt wenn du nicht extra einschaltest und fertig.
Hast du einen link für dieses hetzen geschichte.
Guck ich gleich mal schicke ich dir gleich,
es ist halt relativ die grundversion damit erstmal überhaupt irgendwie war tut es unheimlich einfach zu machen es gibt
eine anleitung von meet auf deren gift,
da steht drauf klickst du hier du hast eine bunte kiste oder eine kiste linus kiste server klicks das klickst du das klickst du das dann fertig da muss man nicht großartig fummeln es wird dann spannend wenn man noch so spezial features mit dazu haben wir
man kann zum beispiel noch ein ein voiceover telefonie provider anbinden und dann kann man auch leute mit.
Normalen telefonleitungen mit hinzunehmen das netz ist eine komponente wie heißt denn gassi
und der yotta drin suggeriert schon in wartet alles geschrieben ist und da wird's dann langsam ein bisschen schlammig geht auch aber da ist dann nicht mehr so mit
drei klicks hier und so aber wenn man jetzt erstmal was haben will wo man sich jetzt nur drauf klicken will wir haben jetzt hier zum beispiel gerade eine session die besteht aus also ich sehe gerade sieben bilder ich sehe mein eigenes serie von tim von rudi von tala von huckel von letty und ich sehe noch den screenshot von tim das kann nämlich auch
man kann ja nicht bloß sich gegenseitig angucken sondern man kann dann auch seinen bildschirm inhalt oder teile davon nur zeigen also bestimmte browserfenster oder nur bestimmte applikationen was ich auch sehr schön finde
es hat auch so funktionen drin wenn man jetzt viele leute dort hat dass man so eine art dass man so eine virtuelle hand heben kann mit ich will jetzt was sagen und dann kann ein moderator der sozusagen ein bisschen bearbeiten hat
sehr viele schöne features ist komplett open source kostet nix und wie gesagt in drei klicks aufzusetzen da gibt's auch ähnliche andere sachen was auch nicht schlecht ist es
zum beispiel in der schon längst bekannten next cloud die ja auch so ein für sagen wir mal für zivilisten draußen zum dropbox ersatz ist open source selber gehostet und so auch dit hat eine eine komponente next cloud talk.
Wo man auch beim browser einfach miteinander schnacken kann und so ist so aus derselben größenklasse und alles andere was danach kommt sind dann mehr oder weniger kostenfreier oder halt eben
produkt und so ne diese geschichte angebote von allmöglichen herstellern einer verschiedener als der nächste,
ob man da nur google hangouts benutzt oder zoom oder facebook tralala oder so ich habe kein facebook-account,
kann man kann man bei facebook auch konferenzen so videokonferenz machen bestimmt hat jemand von euch ein facebook account und traut sich das jetzt zuzugeben.
Ich ich habe.
Frag mal den chat egal also.
Ich habe einen facebookaccount.
Und gibt seine funktionalität um videokonferenzen zu machen.
Keine ahnung ich benutze ihn nie also ich habe nur den account also ich gucke da ab und zu mal rein um so links zu verfolgen und mal zu schauen wie schlimm das alles aussieht und klickt drauf und sieht immer noch alles noch schlimmer aus und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Standard standard facebook verhalten ja also wie gesagt ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen oh clemens empfiehlt da wird
jetzt halt ein ding was man relativ schnell mal auf den server drauf schmeißen kann und sobald ich jetzt aufgehört habe zu labern finde ich diesen post wieder von von hetzer und schickt den mal huckel damit er den
packen kann ich kann ja keinen fleck laufen lassen ich habe nur sechzehn in meinem rechner deswegen.
Der ist schon im slack.
Schon jemand gefunden.
Was der jussi in story ja ja der kam schon der ist ja hier auch schon auf meinem bildschirm die wir den ich hier teile.
Du willst natürlich kann man also so eine instanz für drei vier fünf sechs leute was wir jetzt hier machen ist wirklich easy aufzusetzen da da gehört nicht viel dazu wenn man ein bisschen ernsthafter haben will,
leute die wirklich mit zweistelligen oder teilweise dreistelligen teilnehmerzahlen benutzen
da musst du den server schon noch ein bisschen tunen da solltest du auch noch einen turn server aufsetzen und all solche sachen dass die medien ströme ordentlich durch die gegend strömen und hin und her.
Gibt es denn jetzt noch eine aussage darüber wie viel bandbreite man jetzt braucht weil es ist ja dann auch exponentiell wenn man umso mehr leute man hat.
Das ist schwer zu sagen weil,
diese web c sachen versuchen erstmal schlau zu sein wir versuchen erstmal direkt miteinander zu kommunizieren,
und erst wenn das nicht geht dann fallen sie zurück auf einen modus wo der verkehr über den server geht,
nehmen wir mal an jetzt beispielsweise du sitzt jetzt da in deinem laden bei dir zu hause und hast was aus audi gründen quatsch ist aber jetzt aus keine ahnung was ich gründe im nebenzimmer sitzt jetzt jemand der auch dran teilnimmt
es ist im selben laden dann reden diese beiden instanzen auf jeden fall schon mal direkt miteinander das merkst du auch,
weil sie noch geringeres delay haben und so und dann hängt davon ab was du für ein plastik oder zu hause hast ob der sich halt ordentlich
geboren lässt mit den üblichen methoden dass also auch leute die an unterschiedlichen internetanschlüsse hängen direkt miteinander kommunizieren können und erst wenn das nicht geht,
dann fällt der modus zurück dass sozusagen die daten zentral an ein oder mehrere server gesendet werden die denn die also die media-daten also
bild- und tonmaterial die denn die von dort wieder verteilen deswegen kann man jetzt schlecht vorhersagen geht's nicht genau weiß die teilnehmer wer da ist an welchen anschlüsse mit was für rudern kann ich nicht sagen was,
direkt geht zwischen den teilnehmern und was halt über eine zentrale stelle geht.
Ist auf der einen seite schön was ich jetzt sozusagen selbst optimiert auf der anderen seite ist es halt eben blöd wenn man's halt schlecht vorher berechnen kann du kannst halt eben
du kannst eine situation haben mit zwanzig leuten wo das alles super ist die alle direkt miteinander verbunden sind da hast du ungefähr null last offen server kann aber auch sein du hast eine session wo die leute alle hinterm scheiße internetanschluss sind dann hast du plötzlich fünf videos strömen auf deinem server
nicht nicht so einfach zu sagen.
Also wenn man gigabit hat kommt man auf jeden fall schon mal weit.
Du willst ein gigabit haben und muss jetzt nicht ein gigabit halt irgendwohin also jetzt muss gucken wo sitzen deine teilnehmer sitzen die alle an alle an telekom anschlüssen dann möchtest du gerne in die gigabit haben von einem hosting provider der auch einen ordentlichen telekom link hat,
sprache von dadrüber selber für kabel deutschland vodafone tralala wiese alle heißen diese ganzen großen,
da musste also jetzt einen witz gigabit haben beziehungsweise brauchst gar kein gigawatt erreichen wie ein paar hundert megabit aber die sollen halt eben möglichst
gut kontaktiert sein es ist halt ein gigabit ist nicht ein gigabyte immer mal gibt ein gutes und ein schlechtes gigabit.
Die guten ins töpfchen die schlechten ins töpfchen.
Die schlechten ins töpfchen genau.
Wobei ich aber nicht genau weiß ob das eigentlich die guten ins kröpfchen oder ins töpfchen müssen wie rum war das.
Die guten müssen ins töpfchen weil die guten sind die linsen die schlechten das ist asche oder so müssen ins kröpfchen die werden dann geschluckt.
Warum schluckt man denn das schlechte an.
Des aussortieren für denjenigen der nur das gute zeug haben will.
Und tatsächlich fressen stadttauben steine um körner und samen im magen zerkleinern zu können.
Die gebrüder grimm damals schon alt wussten.
Ist das für den krimms ja ich bin gerade.
Nicht von den gebrüdern die haben ja nur die haben ja nur eingesammelt.
Copy cat.
Sie haben es nicht selber.
In zeiten des digital millennium corporate nicht vorstellbar mehr aber damals haben die einfach,
fremder leute geschichten.
Sie haben nur kompakt.
Hallo.
Genau.
Okay gut dann haben wir noch weitere tipps wie man mit der krise unter der einwirkung von internet kreativ umgehen kann der die wissen das eigentlich bei dir du bist doch gehst du nicht gerade in die lehre.
Das werde ich jetzt herausfinden,
ja ich habe dieses semester das sommersemester so wie es aussieht eine lehrveranstaltung an einer universität in deutschland nicht in berlin also ich kann das dann offiziell sagen wenn ich wirklich den vertrag unterschrieben habe weil,
nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwas sage und dann kommt es am ende doch nicht zur stadt zustande genau aber ich selber habe mir was.
Ich habe ich habe mir halt jetzt erstmal noch nicht so viele gedanken gemacht weil meine lehrveranstaltung nur zwei tage input präsent von mir sind und der letzte dritte tag später dann,
die studenten erzählen mir vorträge aber stefan mein sportfreund
der meinte dann irgendwie zu mir so yeah ich muss mir jetzt mal gedanken machen wie das jetzt ist mit der lehrveranstaltung so der lehrt an der t u u in berlin,
und da ist halt auch so ein bisschen unklar wie werden lehrveranstaltungen gerade stattfinden und da dachte ich mir so vielleicht sollte ich mir da auch mal darüber gedanken machen wer vielleicht nicht so blöd,
und es bringt halt aber auch nicht nur uns technikaffiner menschen dazu darüber nachzudenken wie man lehre gestaltet sondern auch die ganzen leute die jetzt gerade nicht so viel
ahnung haben vielleicht auch überhaupt kein gutes equipment haben aber schon mal so vorproduzieren gegebenenfalls wollen für die lehre
treten halt so verschiedene fragen auf wie das würde ich auch noch mal ganz gerne tim dass du das in die shownotes reinpackst
du hast mal im lautsprecher über gute tonqualität gesprochen und wir haben relativ kurz aber ich glaube auch sehr wirksam angesprochen,
wie man mit diesem tag was du da hast an der wand sich so ein ministudio schonmal bauen kann.
Und freakshow berichtete in folge zweihundertdreiunddreißig und den link mit der folge zum chapter mark war ich auch mal gleich mit in das.
Gute ton ja weil ja auch gleich nochmal was zu sagen.
Ganz kurzer als einschnitt nochmal damit ich's vergesse weil gerade sagst so lehrveranstaltung ist übrigens auch noch jetzt ich habe ja gesagt die grundversion easy-peasy telefon einbinden wartet auch noch hat es ein feature sollte man es erwähnen
du kannst da dein youtube account andocken und dann kannst du halt sagen okay machst du jetzt eine konferenz mit weil es sich drei vier lehrenden oder auch nur du oder wie auch immer okay dann kannst du direkt zu youtube streams aber du kannst halt deine session die du dort machst kannst du gleichzeitig auch an youtube streamen dadurch hast du sozusagen nach hinten
eine skalierung bis zum gärtner das heißt machst wie die session mit drei vier leuten streams das live auf youtube und dann ist es egal ob da drei leute oder viertausend zuschauer
es geht ja nicht mehr auf deinen server und du kannst auch sachen aufzeichnen und so da geht auch,
wollte ich nur noch mit einschmeißen sind noch so module für miete wäre da mal ein bisschen spaß daran hat kann er auch noch mal drin rumwühlen.
Ja dann ist es vielleicht auch was was nee nee das ist eine gute hinweis weil also stefan
alles wissen weiß jede uni weiß nicht alles also jeder probiert auch gerade für sich aus jede uni hat irgendwie ein konzept was sie verfolgt dass dieses semester
was jetzt kommen wird ist halt so einen von spielfeld zum also hoffentlich halt nicht zum leiden der studenten nur studentinnen am ende sondern dass halt irgendwie trotzdem gute lehre dabei rauskommt aber das ist halt so die frage was kann man,
wie kann gute lehre geradeaus sehen wenn man gegebenenfalls keine präsenz der veranstaltung,
abhalten kann und das ist natürlich dann du willst ja eigentlich ein kleines tonstudio wenn's geht also nicht gleich ein tonstudio aber so ein bisschen eine gute audioqualität haben,
und es gibt auch vielleicht fast noch andere lehrenden ja,
hier zuhören auf dem tu blog hat stefan so ein kleines tutorial zusammengeschrieben wie man bild und ton aufzeichnet die
versuchen das halt,
alle irgendwie zu überlegen so wie kann leere grad aussehen wie kann lehrer aussehen wenn sie linear ist also dieser klassische stream oder wie man präsenz lehrveranstaltung hält so man man stellt sich vorne hin und erzählt irgendwas so nach dem motto.
Zur festen zeiten oder was halt vielleicht auch ein bisschen,
einfacher aber auch größere herausforderungen hat ist so was könnte man gegebenenfalls schon vorher aufnehmen und dann,
so ins netz stellen und jeder studierende kann für sich entscheiden wann er diese vorlesung gemacht aber das sind halt so gerade viele sachen die zusammenführen wo viele einfach.
Ist aber noch da ist aber noch arbeit zu leisten also sorry also wenn ich das sehe hier da gibt's da gibt's die abteilung einen podcast aufnehmen podcast ja ja.
Tim tim tim dann mach doch endlich mal ein ein youtube-video wo du alles drin erklärst das.
Ein youtube-video ich.
Man dir wieder so richtig.
Einfach konserviert.
Weiß ja im.
Tuber tim auf den warten wir schon lange.
Du musst mit der zeit gehen willst du ein oller windows recht.
Oder nehmen wir den den den stock man als double den kannst du.
Ich gehe nicht mit der zeit ich bin derzeit voraus das ist was ganz anderes.
Ganz spannend man sieht halt bei so bei so plattformen wie es ist es gilt hat er eine relativ hohe qualität was ihre onlinekurse angeht bis auf die programmierte kurse die finde ich meistens eher.
Die sind super schlecht das sind leute die kannst du sorry ich will niemanden auf den schlips treten aber da läufst du weg das ist so mindere qualität und genau also.
Ja da gibt's halt auf,
youtube bessere kurse und meiner meinung nach und bei so öffentlichen kursen wie halt irgendwie sera oder x,
hast du halt so eine komplette bandbreite von echt guten uni kursen also die haben auch,
medizin kurse die ich teilweise belegt habe die ich wirklich top fand oder so einführung softwareentwicklung piper einführungskurs sich halt wirklich empfehlen kann.
Jetzt reden wir über zwei verschiedene sachen wir haben ja erst geredet über selber unterricht und jetzt seid ihr bei irgendwelchen plattformen die unterrichten.
Das nenne ich das finde ich ist kein unterschied dass ich glaube dass das sollte man mal erwähnen weil nur weil du etwas jetzt aufzeichnet für die tu für was auch immer für eine universität heißt es ja nicht du kannst es zweit verwerten so.
Also die genau diese plattformen die die machen das ja,
schon seit längerem und da sind ja teilweise universitäten dahinter die auch reguläre lehrveranstaltungen darüber abbildenden,
und das ist halt genau das spannende man kann jetzt also wenn man gerade so 'ne lehrveranstaltung planen will eigentlich schon von existierenden plattformen gucken was da so existiert für wohl von den guten sachen als auch von den schlechten sachen und die haben halt,
ein gutes management das hat zum beispiel die lehrveranstaltung alle mit einem transkript hinterlegt sind und dass die dokumente da sind und dass die studenten sich untereinander austauschen können und das ist halt,
man muss das rad nicht unbedingt neu erfinden.
Es gibt ja auch schon super lange gab's ja schon von apple sogar ganz früher itunes jude es wird auch gerade oder university und ja gerade im chat erwähnt war glaube ich das und,
college of music und so und die haben auch schon seit jahren richtig,
qualitativen content online für vorlesungen bei den meisten muss man sich zwar für teuer geld dann den zugang zu den tieferen,
semestern erwerben oder kaufen aber was sie so machen es genau wie du sagst schon eigentlich vorbild genug.
Genau aber das problem ist halt jetzt gerade dass du gegebenenfalls zu hause sitzt in brandenburg vielleicht noch die kacke internetverbindung hast irgendwie nur einen kleinen popel laptop und noch nicht mal ein hetze.
Ey ja nichts gegen brandenburg und land ich habe hier bessert.
Du bist auch der einzige.
Was ich mir selber noch nee nee nee nee die haben hier breit die haben ja breit wegdrücken ausgerollt im ganzen landkreis kein scheiß.
Aber weiß er doch keiner.
Doch doch egal.
Genau aber ich meine es gibt halt auch,
wurde halt auch berichtet dass konferenzen selbst unter der unter den wissenschaftlichen mitarbeitern stattfinden wo halt leute in oranienburg oder was was ist berliner umland sitzen und sie können kein bild anmachen weil funktioniert nicht dann,
die internetverbindung hat man so eine scherze sind halt nochmal ganz andere sachen und eben wenn du selber vielleicht auch nicht so die mittel hast oder nicht so technikaffin wirst
um dir in der wind schiere säuft eine vorlesung zusammenzuschnipseln und zu schneiden und irgendwie nice grafiken mit reinzumachen in dein screencast dass du halt
so eine mischung hast aus was weiß ich ich will meine folien ab die irgendwie
keynote sind und dann mache ich noch meine skizze procreate schiebt da noch das timelabs mit dazu oder so haben sie ja hunderttausend.
Overhead folien vor die webcamera halten.
Oh man könnte ja.
Stell dir so eine glasscheibe auf.
Hallo.
Abfilmen.
Ja
Was ich gerade für halt lehrende auch echt schwierig finde wenn man jetzt nicht eine technikaffiner abteilung oder uni hat ich meine
so standard sozialwissenschaften standard-magazin universitäten die haben ja nicht mal personal die man fragen könnte und da wird auch kein personal zur verfügung gestellt sondern es wird dann irgendwie meistens von den unis angenommen
ihr kümmert euch jetzt drum und das muss irgendwie laufen aber es wird halt weder bezahlt dass sie sich da selbst drum kümmern weil,
mehr aufwand wird eh nicht bezahlt und man hat halt irgendwie auch keine,
keine möglichkeit mal jemanden zu fragen oder eine person zu haben die hält standardmäßig jetzt einfach nur alles online stellt sein das ist halt dann alles bei den einzelpersonen und dann kann man glaube ich auch nicht gleichbleibende qualität über verschiedene lehrveranstaltungen hinweg anbieten.
Und selbst wenn du so eine abteilung hast also die werden also die sind halt gerade permanent überlastet weil jetzt alle natürlich ankommen und sagen so meine lehrveranstaltung wie was kann ich jetzt machen und was brauche ich für equipment
und dann ist ja auch so ein bisschen die frage also das eine ist halt so der technische kram der bei uns lehrenden liegt und der andere teil ist so
wie wirklich das halt auch auf die studenten aus also sagen wir mal ich entscheide mich 'ne lehrveranstaltung zu machen und ich nehme alles vorher auf und die studentinnen sollen dann nur noch mal den den podcast abonnieren oder das video sich anschauen
das war's dann so also das war's dann geht eh nicht du musst halt immer jetzt auch definitiv sagen okay wir haben hier online zeiten
da könnt ihr mir fragen stellen wir machen dann halt das meeting nicht in der person also in in in person sondern im indiz oder wo auch immer.
Aber für einige leute funktioniert das halt nicht weil sie sich irgendwie nicht gut organisieren können also ich meine
man sieht ja gerade dass einige leute ein großes problem damit zu haben alleine zu hause zu sitzen und zu arbeiten so das ist bei studenten natürlich nicht anders was anderen total in die karten spielt weil
sie so arbeiten oder sie so lernen können ist es bei anderen halt wieder nicht
auch als als lehrerin da fehlt dir dann natürlich so das feedback direkt so dann sprichst du in deine kamera rein,
siehst nix und alles wird schon irgendwie passen aber du hast halt nicht das feedback von den studenten das heißt es kommt dann halt auch wieder vielleicht nur von einzelpersonen und man hat nicht so eine richtige gruppendynamik die in so einer lehrveranstaltung.
Darf ich da an der stelle nochmal die trommel trommeln die ich schon seit längeren zeit trommel weil ich bin ja ja fan.
Hier wird alles improvisiert.
Siehste feature wir brauchen einen drumrum.
Ja genau.
Ja ich meine wo du jetzt gerade sagst mit ich habe ja nicht die dynamik in der lehrveranstaltung die ich sonst habe wenn das digital ist
ich denke halt dass man eben jetzt nicht nur darüber nachdenken muss wie man das was man bisher in präsenz gemacht hat digital machen kann sondern dass man eben darüber nachdenken muss wie kann ich alles was ich gerade überhaupt tue
durch das digitale anders machen dass es vielleicht sogar auch besser funktioniert und nicht nur überhaupt funktioniert sondern dass es besser funktioniert und,
ich muss mich vielleicht an also erstens ich werde mich jetzt wiederholen wer irgendwie laut bundespolitik zuletzt gehört hat und so weiter wird es wahrscheinlich alles schon kennen die leier jetzt schon ein paar mal runter gespult aber ich bin halt ich hab halt bisher noch kein argument dagegen gefunden das ist diese idee dieses flip,
classrooms dass man halt einfach sagt repetitiv dinge immer wieder neu zu machen und vorlesungen ist ja am ende
immer wieder dasselbe in gewisser hinsicht weil du halt grundlagen vermittelst etcetera du stellst dich da irgendwie hin und saß halt so das so und so und so und so okay das kann top aktuell sein das kann sein dass jemand ist irgendwie jedes mal wieder neu auf würzt et cetera alles wunderbar aber im prinzip geht es ja in diesen vorlesungen
primär darum ein grundwissen zu vermitteln,
grundwissen vermitteln wissen wir alle funktioniert ganz wunderbar über video kanäle man kann sich irgendwie vorträge anschauen es gibt irgendwie ted talks es gibt irgendwie eine million youtube-channel zu jedem möglichen scheiß.
Klar da ist das wissen halt nicht definiert und an der stelle muss man auch reingrätschen und sagen okay eine uni die sozusagen ein grundwissen vor voraussetzt,
sollte dieses grundwissen auch selber einfach bereitstellen aber eben nicht in form von präsenz,
vorlesung die immer das problem haben dass irgendjemand dann doch nicht da ist weil krank weil geht nicht keine ahnung ja oder es zumindest super mega convenient weil weit weg früher aufstehen und was nicht alles,
sowas kann man wunderbar in videoform veranstaltungen packen die man vorher aufnimmt die man auch durch,
design die man auch immer wieder verbessert die man immer wieder anreichert die man entsprechend multimedial macht und nicht nur personen steht vor tafel.
Oder vielleicht digitales weit board und was es nicht alles schon schönes gibt da sagt einfach so dass das wissen was du verstanden haben muss und dann prüft man dieses wissen online,
durch eine entsprechende überprüfung und dann ist die eigentliche präsenzveranstaltung,
kommt später nachdem man bewiesen hat dass man dieses grundwissen erstmal,
aufgesammelt hat damit hast du erst mal mit leuten zu tun die alle irgendwie auf derselben ebene sind und dann kannst du auch immer noch das feedback bekommen klar diese komponente fällt jetzt auch weg beziehungsweise dieses präsente im sinne von wir sind im selben raum fällt natürlich weg,
das kann man ja war jetzt,
auch nochmal neu denken in der aktuellen situation mit mit digitalen kommunikationskanäle aber mein kernpunkt ist einfach der man muss einfach dieses modell neu denken wie unterricht überhaupt dargereicht wird.
Das wird jetzt aber höchstwahrscheinlich nicht in der aktuellen situation mal eben so passieren ne.
Nein nichts wird in dieser aktuellen situation so passieren aber uns ist glaube ich auch auch klar dass die aktuelle situation ist natürlich der mega katalysator alles was bisher schon irgendwie kurz davor war findet jetzt statt alles was jetzt,
obwohl es sich total dagegen gewehrt hat ja und immer gesagt hat so einen scheiß kommt mir nicht ins haus muss ich jetzt trotzdem damit durch auseinandersetzen das das ist das interessante an dieser situation entweder du fährst,
sogar ich ja ja gut.
Remote podcast.
Ja klar natürlich logisch und ich werde vielleicht auch feststellen heute und es zeichnet sich hier auch schon so ein bisschen ab so ja geht auch irgendwie,
hat.
Geht voll super tim.
Ja das habe ich befürchtet soll ich brauche gleich mein studio ab hier.
Na ja es geht aber es geht aber weil alle.
Ich nehme ich nehme ich da auch,
ich nehme ich da gar nicht raus ja das das ich verstehe auch dass es ein prozess ist man ist es halt gewohnt man macht das so man weiß auch was man daran hat man fürchtet so ein bisschen die veränderung man denkt sich was der geier und überhaupt läuft ja eigentlich und so logisch
das kann die folge sein und ich werde ja auch meine schlüsse daraus ziehen aus dieser aktuellen situation und natürlich merke ich auch
dass vieles ganz gut funktioniert weil wir aber auch hier schon so lange zusammen gesessen haben.
Sie hören tim beim altwerden zu.
Nein zu während der schön am jungbrunnen raus schlürft.
Und wie du es auch gerade so schön gesagt hast deine aufgabe wird jetzt sein das wissen über podcast und guten ton in einem audiovisuellen,
danke festzuhalten tim deine aufgabe für dich.
Ach so na ja gut ich meine ultraschall ich meine was ich vorhin zitiert habe ist einen podcast auf ich lese mal vor was auf dieser website stellt einen podcast aufnehmen,
podcast lassen sich einfach mit diversity erstellen nein.
Tim nur weil du es besser weißt dann sprich es raus aber machen die nicht andere dafür an dass sie das wissen noch nix.
Da habe ich seit zehn jahren davon.
Ja wahrscheinlich hört dich nicht die welt also geh endlich auf youtube verdammte scheiße und rät dort.
Was soll ich denn da erzählen deiner meinung nach.
Tutorials erstellen eine schöne tutorials reise von von a nach so macht man podcast und warum macht man es nicht mit zum beispiel diesen programm ist es vielleicht was ist die minimale.
Dann begleiten wir tim wir zu turmen fährt und sein auto.
Oh ja blogs.
Schöne homestory und dann fährst du nach hause und dann dann klebst du die panele an die wand und.
Ok
Ja wie zum beispiel das panele ding essen ein guter punkt also viele wissen gerade nicht jetzt ruhe tim ich rede.
Bitte euch wie kriegt ihr das monetarisiert,
hab ich euch schon.
Nur immer sagen dass sie dass sie die glocke anmachen sollen und abonnieren.
Hier unten kommentieren und.
Like and stop script.
Übrigens habe ich euch schon von meiner neuen matratze erzählt,
schlafe ja so gut jetzt in letzter zeit.
Auch ich auch ich bin ich bin bereit den wandel anzunehmen ja ich will nur dass alle anderen.
Noch mal ein tutorial wie man ordentlichen ton produzieren kann mit vielleicht auch low budget mitteln so punkt.
Okay aber es muss mir mehr als nur letti erzählen.
Das tue ich auch gerade.
Ich habe dir den screenshot von stefan schon geschickt also ich schicke dir dann auch nochmal.
Ja ihr seid schon zwei aber leute hören hier zu wenn ich ich bin jetzt total offen also erstens ich habe mich ja sowieso schon bereit erklärt das wollte ich an dieser stelle auch nochmal kurz preisgeben ich langweile mich natürlich auch so ein bisschen und wenn ihr mich mal,
wenn du nicht mehr du wahrscheinlich nicht aber viele.
Ich langweilige mich auch nicht ich arbeite.
Gold aber viele leute ja weil du ja weil die auch wirklich gemerkt hat dass draußen eine krise ist keine erzählt was ja alles,
genau business ne ich wollte nur kurz sagen falls andere podcasts lust haben mich mal als gast zu haben,
dann quatscht mich einfach an ich habe gerade viel zeit dafür das passt schon irgendwie ich war auch schon bei paar podcast zu gast kann ich nachher nochmal erzählen aber ich bin da durchaus offen also ganz ehrlich ich will ja nicht alt und knöchern rüber kommen,
allein schon als gründen.
Wie hältst du dich denn in zeiten der zuhause isolation gesund.
Gesund gar nicht ich fresse ihn scheunendrescher ich bin fett.
Machst du keinen sport.
Ich mache doch ich mache tatsächlich sport ich laufe laufen wieder schwimmen geht gerade nicht.
Ja
das ist halt dass es halt auch glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger aspekt der vor allem jetzt langfristige quarantäne wichtig ist also ja auf jeden fall soziale interaktion da haben wir ja jetzt quasi besprochen was so so geht,
aber wenn das jetzt noch so zwei drei monate weitergeht haben hat man typischerweise dann so andere probleme mit zu wenig bewegung schlechter ernährung und ausgewogene ernährung,
aber.
Beraterin tala was empfehlen sie uns.
Nicht nur fitness beratung also dass jeder sich irgendwie versuchen soll,
halbwegs angemessen zu ernähren es sollte klar sein muss halt jeder gucken was funktioniert und gibt es mehr als genug da aber zum beispiel kleinere portionen man bewegt sich doch deutlich deutlich weniger,
also wenn man sonst so unterwegs ist kann man halt je nachdem ob man mit öffentlichen pferd oder nicht mindestens sechs bis zehntausend schritte verbuchen manche wie lotti noch mehr,
aber wenn ich habe halt.
Gesagt ich esse schon wieder zu viel.
Nein ich habe gesagt du bewegst dich mehr als ich wenn man halt.
Hast du dich selber dick genannt.
Nein habe ich nicht ich habe nur den wissenschaftlichen beweis wenn ich ein bürotag habe bewege ich mich zwischen dreitausendsiebenhundert und sechstausend schritten mit medizinisch akkuraten,
trecker was schon echt nicht viel ist wenn ich aber den ganzen tag zu hause bin bin ich bei siebenhundert schritten,
das ist halt auf dauer gerade für leute die es nicht gewöhnt sind,
ein anderer anderer kaloriengrundumsatz deshalb es reicht normalerweise kleinere portionen zu essen.
Schatz vielleicht sollten wir wirklich mal darüber reden dass du dich endlich mal mehr bewegen solltest.
Ich bin faul was ich aber auch ganz wichtig finde ist ruhig vitamin d und zwei zum beispiel zu sich zu nehmen also,
wenn man jetzt wenn wenn's jetzt wirklich noch zwei drei monate,
heim isolation ist ruhig zu füttern weil vitamin d kriegt man halt nur mit sonne gebildet und wenn man nicht
eine stunde draußen in der sonne ist hat man da nach dem winter einen schnellen einen mangel der halt auch zu anderen sachen führen kann.
War gerade zwei jetzt nochmal oder für was ist das.
Auch ein vitamin müsste ich nachgucken im zweifel falls die nerven.
Klar den habe ich hier auch am start obwohl ich habe hier echt zur sonne übelst ich war gerade eben kurz im im nord flügel weil ich mir meine kulinarischen genuss.
Musst du da sozusagen über den außen über das berühmte draußen und da ist hier übrigens sternenklare nacht mit schönem schönem mond und tralala und soße und scharf hier draußen aufm aufm land.
Habe vor ein paar tagen die eis gesehen wie sie rüber flog.
Du wohnst jetzt auch fast auf dem land habe ich gehört ja fast.
Es ist nach berlin.
Aber die häuser sind nicht so hoch.
Ja als land nähe das stimmt schon.
Ich hätte ja auch noch eine empfehlung für gesellschaftlich sein ohne physische gesellschaft,
die war ja schon bei einem sozialen event dabei und dass ich auch kürzlich eingeführt wurde nämlich die örtliche kalkar sonnengruß,
wurde jetzt auch ins kalkar sonst spielen eingeführt genau und jetzt gibt es.
Hörte sehr erfolgreich.
Genau ich habe viel gewonnen ja aber davon,
gesehen ist das ja ein sehr soziales event man trifft sich und schnappt und trinkt und so weiter und das fällt jetzt
aus und da hab ich kürzlich auf twitch jemanden gesehen der hat mir ein neues konzept für so brettspiele auf computern und so vorgestellt und zwar,
von so einem indy developer den table top simulator.
Das coole ist dass es eigentlich nur eine sandbox wo sozusagen so würfel werfen dinge aufheben figuren setzen karten drehen quasi einmal gelöst ist in einer unity engine das heißt es läuft auch auf allem was irgendwie ein bisschen spricht
und dann gibt's sozusagen entweder kostenpflichtige meistens von den original herstellern brettspiel adaptionen dafür oder auch von community gemachten kostenlosen adoptionen und zum beispiel kalker sonnen
gibt es auch als community oder steam-workshop spiel mit allen erweiterungen und das coole ist halt das auch gleich voice chat drin und das ist dann sozusagen wie,
ein spieltisch vor dir du kannst auch den table flippen wenn du so richtig hart frustriert bist und alles fliegt umher,
aber du musst halt auch wirklich so deine figürchen setzen oder wenn da einer monopoly spielt die geldscheine
fühlte sich tatsächlich sehr sehr lauschig das müssten wir jetzt mal probieren weil die michi mir schon gesagt hat dass,
christian sehr traurig ist dass jetzt die personengruppe.
Sehr heiß aufs spielen ja da vielleicht nochmal zu sagen also taler und ich haben früher sehr intensiv tabea top games gezockt als wir auch noch näher beieinander gewohnt haben was jetzt.
Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich auch eine regelmäßige brettspielgruppe die sich jetzt,
dann durch promotion aufgelöst hat und jetzt bin ich ab und zu nochmal eine also table top simulator ist halt auch für für komplexere brettspiele nicht nur kakao sonnenfuchs ist das ganz gut.
Hast du da schon einen link irgendwo reingeworfen ja dings.
Ja
Links links links.
Dummerweise oder.
Doch irgendwie hier rein oder so weil ich wie gesagt kein slack habe.
Wie du hast kein slack.
Ich habe nur sechzehn auf meiner maschine.
Die seiten sind.
Clemens ist gelöst was randproblem also slack verbraucht gerade bei mir mit vier oder fünf offenen channels irgendwie zweihundert megabyte also schaffst du auch.
Installiert mal du kriegst jetzt hier keine keine sonderbehandlung.
Und mir du dich beim essen ich werde auch immer angepflaumt.
Das stimmt allerdings ja bei mir ist das leck bei achthundertfünfzig megabyte.
In diesen zeiten ist es noch wichtiger mute dich beim essen.
Hatte früher ja eine schöne schöne standalone app die ist jetzt auch wieder.
Genau die coding monkeys haben da sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen.
Ich dachte davon redet die ganze zeit.
Es gibt einmal den allgemeinen table top simulator und dann gibt es eine spezifische carcassonne app.
Moment dann habe ich das nicht verstanden also tom was heißt denn timo top simulator.
Du hast nicht zugehört denn mal wieder also table top simulator,
box für table top games wo nur so die basic moves die implementiert sind die du brauchst um tablet top games zu spielen und kein spitze.
Also top brettspiele okay das ja sorry den begriff ja okay gut also brettspiele.
Alter ja genau also der brettspiel simulator der nur.
Mut.
Nicht dran an dem button.
Genau also der der baute halt so ein virtuelles zimmer und die ganze physik zum würfeln und so weiter in drei d mit voice chat und allem die spiele musst du dir halt dann,
reinladen in diese welt sozusagen und es gibt verschiedene implementieren entweder kommerzielle adaptionen dafür,
von den herstellern selbst oder eben von der community und wie gesagt kalkar sonne gibt's als community edition mit allen erweiterungen allen regeln und punkte zählen und so weiter,
aber ich fand die idee halt ganz gut dass man einfach nur so ein so eine plattform für brettspiele online macht mit allen features die man so haben will und dann kann sich die leute austoben und in dieser sandbox bauen was sie wollen.
So ein bisschen equipment oder was auch ganz gut funktioniert ist roll,
das ist halt für pennen paper da kann man dann sein kartenmaterial seine spieler und so weiter reinladen man kann in der es nur
website interface kann dort halt auch solche chat machen und hat das dann halt für panel paper rollenspiele oder oder andere ähnliche,
würfelspiele,
funktioniert halt auch ganz gut früher habe ich halt es gibt die die drachen zwinge community das heißt selbst wenn man jetzt nicht freunde hat mit denen man brettspiele oder per paypal,
spielen kann ich habe die drachen zwinge community,
als sehr sehr angenehm empfunden und die haben halt auch viele einsteigerfreundliche runden und dann gibt es halt irgendwie ein teamspeak server und man kann einfach mit leuten alles mögliche an,
systemen ausprobieren.
Drachenfest zwinger.
Swinger oder zwinge.
Tramsweg club.
Das ist eine andere community.
Drachen zwinger club sendungs-inhalte.
Oh oh gott.
Achso das gibt's übrigens auch noch vorher noch bei sachen waren es gibt ja schon das schon seit ewigkeiten bekannt und benutzte moomba oder team speaker oder wie auch immer wo man sich auch einzelne dinge aufsetzen kann es halt nicht so sophistication mit scampi sharing aber.
Du springst clemens du springst wir sind bei tablet.
Gerade erwähnt ich weiß wurde aber gerade erwähnt.
Ja nee das ist schon relevant.
Ja also gerade weil man halt sonst schwer paper spielen kann ohne voice,
das funktioniert halt also auch teamspeak zum beispiel hat erdogan wo man einfach da drin irgendwie roll trendy machen kann und gut ist.
Ich sehe auf diesem tablet top simulator gar kein kakao sorten wie hast du denn das damit gespielt.
Dass das ein zweiter link im slack unter dem tablet top simulator,
und da sind auch so videos von dem kalker sonnendeck den ton bitte gleich ausmachen und nicht streamen weil der ton von beiden videos ist ziemlich könnte von deinem youtube-video profitieren ähm.
Tim du wirst gebraucht.
Aber ja man sieht auf jeden fall in etwa wie es funktioniert dass,
würde ich auf jeden fall gerne mal mit der personengruppe die tage ausprobieren natürlich gibt's auch diese coding monkeys app jetzt gerade wieder im app store noch oder für begrenzte zeit das heißt wer.
Zurückgekommen.
Wieder aber ich glaube nur kurz ja hans im glück hat die lizenz zurück haben wollen.
Ach nee echt.
Ja weil sie eine eigene app gemacht haben jetzt für ios und android gehen soll und die aber scheiße.
Da müssen wir mal da können wir mal kurz reingrätschen weil tal und ich haben das nämlich vor kurzem versucht und die sind bei brett spielwelten mehr drauf gegangen das ist der letzte scheiß geworden also wir haben das nicht zum laufen bekommen das,
kann man einfach nicht spielen deswegen wäre das spielen will auf dem gerät unbedingt von dem coding monkeys runterladen.
Und wie lange läuft jetzt die neue lizenz also ist das dann haben sie jetzt eingesehen dass es.
Das war da habe ich keine infos dann müsstest du doch mal fragen aber es kam jetzt halt kurz die meldung es ist noch mal kurzzeitig verfügbar es kann aber sein dass es danach wieder runtergenommen wird also schnell zuschlagen.
Ja das würde ich empfehlen.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe jetzt nicht so das hand zum glück die jetzt unbedingt jetzt zurückhaben wollte sondern die hatten halt eben keine ahnung fünfjahresvertrag oder sonst irgendwas jahres,
der lief halt jetzt eben aus aber okay klar aber kommt im endeffekt für die benutzer auf dasselbe hinaus aber werdet halt
wer das hat kann es natürlich noch weiter benutzen und die haben mir gesagt dass sie ihren server noch jetzt erstmal auf unbestimmte zeit weiter betreiben also werdet jetzt als multiplayer geben betreiben will da brauchst du immer so einen server dazwischen,
das geht jetzt noch eine ganze weile.
Mit erlangen.
Schöne ab die hat mir immer gut gefallen weil sie einfach auch schön war.
Nochmal erwähnt.
Gamescon aber läuft mit erlangen.
Na dann läuft da ja noch eine weile.
Nochmal erwähnen dom hat einen,
spiel sonja drin dieser solitär motor spielt man gegen sich gegen sich selber prinzipiell das ist super lustig und man kann so richtig gut fluchen dabei.
Und ich spiele mit mir selbst.
Ein sehr schönes feature.
Und die spiele mit mir selbst spiele mit mir selbst ich spiele mit mir selbst.
Die meisten meiner physischen brettspiele haben auch ein single player oder das ist eins der kauf kriterium.
Immer noch nicht das tablet spielt hier.
Ja parks ich weiß es geht gerade schwierig aber ich komme generell irgendwie leider nicht so richtig zum spielen ich weiß auch nicht wieso.
Weil ich weil wir keinen urlaub haben vielleicht weil wir arbeiten.
Urlaub.
Arbeiten.
Urlaub könnte jetzt leute übel nehmen den ausdruck urlaub.
Das ist nein das ist das ist wir haben generell keinen urlaub wir sind quasi selbstständig selbst und ständig und so und unser urlaub ist ins wasser gefallen das kommt noch dazu.
Welcher achso der zweite der zweite wird auch irgendwas ins wasser fallen.
Ja das heißt ja kein urlaub keine ausreden ja,
aber um,
zurück zur schöneren themen waffenstillstand tim hat ja vor zwei sendungen oder so schon von dem tollen waffeleisen von clear geschwärmt das ist in.
Ist mir zwischen bei mir gelandet,
das lustige ist ich habe halt den vorgänger das heißt irgendwie ursprüngliches waffeleisen habe ich mir vor zehn jahren zugelegt neues waffeleisen mit fancy beschichtung,
ist in aktueller variante und ich kann jetzt tatsächlich so parallel waffeln tests machen und
ich bin halt immer noch auf der suche nach einem veganen waffeln rezept was funktioniert weil die alte beschichtung da ist das problem dass tatsächlich die waffeln so sehr an dem eisen einem gusseisen kleben,
dass die dann so aufreißen und man hat extrem dünne knusprige aber halt nicht fluffige waffeln aber mit dem neuen eisen bleiben die halt zusammen weil das so toll fancy antihaft beschichtet ist,
das ist jetzt eins der probleme ich habe hier genug zeit um nebenbei in dem massen waffel produktion einzusteigen und hat bestimmt schon drei baches gemacht mit unterschiedlichen misch verhältnissen.
Sag mal was für ein was für eine waffeleisen liga von welcher waffeleisen liga sprechen wir jetzt gerade.
Hausfrauen klasse die hausfrauen klasse also das ist.
So unter hundert euro.
Knapp hundert euro also die mitunter hundert euro gibt es glaube ich auch eine variante
die sind aber nicht schwer genug du brauchst halt so ein bisschen eigengewicht von den waffeleisen damit die halt gleichmäßig sind wenn die zu leicht sind gehen die zu schnell auf und dann werden sie nicht knusprig genug,
und das ist so ich glaube genau hundert euro oder so und ich bin wie gesagt ich habe das ding seit zehn jahren und liebe es,
göttin und jetzt habe ich ein zweites womit ich gegen testen kann.
Ich habe nämlich ein bei meiner ehemaligen firma gab es einen kollegen der
bei jeder gelegenheit von seinem waffeleisen schwärmte was er sich zum halben preis irgendwie,
auf ebay geschossen hat und das dann einfach mit so einem kabel fix wieder repariert hat und das kostet glaube ich neu irgendwie achthundert euro oder so und so ein doppelwochenende.
Ja das sind dann für die belgischen.
Genau ja ich habe den namen auch gerade nicht im kopf aber deswegen habe ich viele vorträge zum thema waffeleisen,
gewollt und ungewollt gehört deswegen wollte ich nur mal gucken wo jetzt dein waffeleisen quasi.
Nee nee das ist das waffeleisen ist herr herz waffeln also ist halt kindheit und ich also belgischen.
Nur belgische waffeln sind richtige waffeln.
Die sind mir zu.
Die sind so unhandlich im mund.
Ja und zu dick und machen so extrem satt und die herzt waffeln sind halt.
Kleinere portionen taler.
Na ja aber wenn du so einen teig machst.
Waffeln die nicht satt machen damit du mehr davon essen kannst oder.
Ja ja und besser sind halt besser zu funktionieren also so ein waffelteig geht halt nur ab einer gewissen mindestmenge und mehr als eine belgische waffeln also scheitere ich,
aber wenn du dann halt drei machen musst.
Na ja aber wenn du den gleiche menge teig in die eine form wächst oder in die andere form backst hast du immerhin hinterher immer noch die gleiche anzahl von gebackener waffel oder sehe ich das jetzt.
Ja aber die dünnen lassen sich besser wegstecken so nebenbei weil du heute in einem sinne so ein herz einfach der reinhard ja das.
Kann man besser dick werden von.
Auf jeden fall wenn man es richtig time.
Aber immerhin weiß ich jetzt wer das ganze mehl kauft also ist ja schon mal gut.
Nee ich ich komme hier an kein mehl hier ist ausverkauft hier ist krisen zustand.
Da muss ich ja echt das glück haben hier dass ich immer wenn ich einkaufen gehe sowohl toilettenpapier als auch mehr finde ich verrate euch jetzt nicht wo ich wohne.
Ja also.
Na ja ich habe im im sommer habe ich bei bei einer größeren veranstaltung noch zwanzig kilogramm mehl das dort über war abgegriffen und davon davon backe ich immer noch pizza insofern.
Dass keine motten viel reinkommt und uns dann ist das ganz schnell weg.
Nee ist bis jetzt nicht.
Was bei mir das problem ist ist dass die hefe tatsächlich sich lehrt und kein nachschub da sitzt muss ich schon trocken hier verkaufen aber mir hat letztens mal jemand den tipp gegeben wie man hefe dann selber vermehren kann ist eigentlich auch relativ naheliegend,
ich packe meinen link dazu den chat falls ihr noch einen rest gehabt und eine silikon eiswürfel schale oder so dann,
könnt ihr euch das weiterhelfen kommt sofort ich muss das mal kurz aus meinem.
Ach du meinst einfach trocken trockenhefe in frische hefe verwandelt sozusagen.
Ja ich habe also das ist jetzt in dem fall frische hefe in mehr frische hefe verwandeln aber das sollte genauso mit trockenhefe vom.
Ja die hilfe ist dieselbe eigentlich.
Also wenn du wenn du mal richtig viel hefe anzüchten willst dann empfehle ich bier brauen.
Hier ich packe mal den link in den slack warte,
da wird es schon oder moment ist das das wildtierhilfe züchten moment ah ja nee das ist das wild hilfe selber machen also wenn ihr trockenfrüchte hat moment da gibt's auch den link zum den anderen auch noch gleich moment,
ah da kommt er schon und das ist zum.
Smart ist ja auch ein toller name.
Ja ja ja da hat sich auch jemand richtig gefreut wahrscheinlich als sie den gefunden haben nun gut also hoffentlich macht es das in die shownotes dann könnt ihr alle hefe züchten.
Macht es gut sind wir bereit für apple themen oder noch nicht.
Allzeit bereit.
Also ich ich hab ich hab's nur am rande gelesen so irgendwie.
Lass uns mal über apple reden dann ist das dass es vom tisch weil ich muss darüber reden es ist es ist wichtig.
Öffne dich.
Für mich,
apple hat einen computer rausgebracht den ich fast.
Nein.
Fast gekauft hätte doch fast.
Wieso nur fast.
Ich habe ihn bestellt und fünf tage später hat er die bestellung storniert.
Yes.
Du alter mekka kopf hast zu sehr sich beschwert und jetzt wollen.
Nein ich habe nein nein nein nein nein ich habe also falls noch jemand nicht mitbekommen hat weil ist ja gerade krise es gibt neue macbook erst,
und holladiho sie haben tatsächlich es geschafft da mal richtige prozessoren rein zu bauen wie es zumindest den anschein hat
so den ersten benchmarks glauben darf und sie haben eine tastatur ohne touchpad mit escape taste mit korrekten cursortasten und so weiter also all das
worüber schon tausend mal nee.
Okay die cursortasten sehen komisch aus aber ich habe auch hier ich habe hier so einen laptop habe mir einen laptop geliehen und er hat auch eine skeptisch das macbook er vom letzten jahr nur der hat halt nicht diese cursortasten tv form aber ansonsten.
Und auch nicht die schöne.
Die taste prallt ja die taste prallt.
Butterfly tastatur ging einfach mal gar nicht und irgendwie double core und überhaupt
dieses wetter fortschritt und jetzt haben wir halt irgendwie quatsch prozessoren ordentliche tastatur wie es den anschein hat
ich habe die ja selber noch nicht oder habe ich doch ich habe schon mal auf so einer tastatur ein bisschen rum getippt es ist macht es sich soweit erstmal macht er erstmal keinen schlechten eindruck.
Aber nach wie vor bis sechzehn.
Damit komme ich auch klar mit sechzehn gigabyte ram komme ich total klar ich komme auch mit zwei terabyte klar also das war für mich auch noch so ein kriterium das musst du schon irgendwie drin sein.
Viele usb-port und haben die dinge.
Das ist das problem.
Kommst du auch mit dem preis klar wenn du den so zusammen konfiguriert hast.
Ich achte nicht auf den preis ich kaufe das einfach.
Ach deswegen wolltest du mir auch gleich ein neues mit kaufen das ist aber nett.
War das originalzitat aus aus wir können auch anders.
Sorry ich.
Spielt keine rolle oder so.
Du ich habe eh keine alternative zum mack weil es gibt keine alternative zu mack ja jetzt kommt jetzt kommt hier wahrscheinlich.
Kannst du den sechzehn zoll.
Nein jetzt kommen die leute mit irgendwie mach dir doch einen hacken tusch und so weiter eckentor und laptop gibt's nicht und,
ja mitgegangen mitgefangen ich will mekka haben und ich bin halt technologisch bis neulich aufgefallen dass ich,
im prinzip obwohl ich mir immer wieder neue macbook erst gekauft habe in letzten jahren und jetzt sozusagen auf einem fünfzehn am modell also das letzte was rausgekommen ist was noch eine ordentliche tastatur hatte festhänge fünf jahre alt,
und ich im prinzip seit neunzehnhundert man kann das ding raus,
das erste richtige macbook air mit keil form wann war das.
Das erste macbook erde waren wir in der uni taler das musst du zweitausendneun gewesen sein oder zweitausend zweitausendacht zweitausendneun.
Das erste in keil.
Neun würde ich meinen.
Das erste in keil form nicht das erste.
Nee das erste in kreis.
Zehn irgendwie ja irgendwie sowas also im prinzip bin ich seit zehn jahren auf demselben modell ist wirklich absurd weil mich die pros irgendwie nie so richtig angesprochen haben die war mir alle zu klobig,
und ich würde jetzt so ein macbook pro dreizehn zoll wahrscheinlich wenn sie es rausbringen wer für mich auch eine option aber ist halt noch nicht da also dachte ich mir so ok scheiß drauf ich bestell das jetzt einfach obwohl es eben nur diese zwei usb ports hat was ich.
Ist besser als einer.
Ja aber es ist es ist einfach es ist es ist es schmerzt,
sind ja auch beide auf einer seite also einer links einer rechts,
ganz andere thematik so aber beide ports auf einer seite und dann nur zwei,
und dann hatte ich das ding schon bestellt und da habe ich natürlich auch gleich wieder maximale konfiguration geklickt und irgendwie schnellerer prozessor dachte ich so jetzt hast du schon wieder ein sieben bestellt,
weil letzte mal als ich das gemacht habe war das eigentlich in ihren fehler weil das ding dann so viel lüftet,
musste ich wieder nicht so ist das ist auch wieder so ein ausfall dieser sieben oder kam apple an und meinte so ja aufgrund eines fehlers wurde ihre bestellung storniert,
ok
fünf jahre als gedauert und ich war bereit mal wieder einen computer zu kaufen und wenn ich das mache kommt apple sagten der.
No
Nix mehr wein freund ja und jetzt bin ich in der in der beruhigenden situation dass ich eigentlich mein vollständig nachgegeben habe aber jetzt trotzdem wieder in diesem moment bin wo ich drüber nachdenken kann.
Oder hat für dich entschieden.
Ob die zeit ob die zeit schon gekommen ist für mich und ein neues macbook und jetzt seid ihr dran.
Ja ist sie.
No care.
Was rudi sagt.
Das ist ja nicht die frage ob es danach besser ist ich meine es kann ja alles noch viel schlimmer werden dadurch.
Also ich würde ja nach wie vor sagen dass das,
froh dass ich jetzt hier so seit einigen monaten wahrscheinlich schon benutze gefühlt catey macbook pro ist und wenn sie das bei dem macbook er auch hinbekommen haben dann gibt es keinen grund das nicht zu haben.
Was dieses.
Diese sechzehn zoll denkt oder.
Ja es hat ja auch viel ports ja eben.
Aber wann also wann brauchst du denn vier ports.
Immer eigentlich.
Hallo.
Hat dein bisheriges.
Schließt er denn da an.
Also ich ich bin unterwegs so dann habe ich strom dran,
dann habe ich muss ich unter umständen mein telefon darüber laden dann habe ich mein audiointerface dran sind schon mal drei.
Was auch alles immer gleichzeitig passieren logischerweise.
Klar weil ich ja während während der sendung,
weil ich während der sendung ja internet brauche okay mit dem iphone elf ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so kritisch dass man das ding die ganze zeit laden muss während man sich permanent mit internet darüber versorgt aber das ist halt sozusagen aber vor allem dieses links rechts ding ist natürlich auch noch so ein thema so.
Links rechts ist ein thema aber ansonsten kommst du auch mit weniger hin weil das meiste kladderadatsch warte externe anschließend schließe eh nicht mit usb c an sondern schließt mit usb zwei drei.
Ist ja egal es ist ja ein port ich meine der.
Ja aber da kannst du natürlich mit einem mit ich habe einen sohn für meinen laptop,
ein so ein ein so ein multi hauptding wo ich übrigens mal darauf hinweisen möchte was man da durch als als apple-nutzer haben möchte ist was noch einen alten display-port hat also nicht bloß eine arsch ich verstehe dich bauen da immer nach vorne stellen dran
also nicht bloß den standardmäßigen sport sondern auch noch so ein mini display-port dann nehme ich seine ganzen alten apple glotzen da schön anschließen kann und da geht's strom rein da kommt strom hinten raus ansonsten hatte den jede menge usb
ports wo man seinen externen plakat inklusive telefon zum laden anhängen kann also dann fertig und hier jetzt in dem setup in der werkstatt,
an dem an meinem dick ist eher wie ich schon sagte der erde hat zwei ports da steckt
nur die glotze dran ich habe so eine so eine samsung hat siebenundzwanzig zoll glotze mit usb c an der hängt hinten alle dran auch ladekabel und tralala und telefon und
hier seit fokus reiter und so weiter hängt da alle dran und da geht ein einziges kabel in den macbook r der versorgt den mit strom und mit allen möglichen daten und bild und tralala und soße und scharf und unterwegs,
ja ich habe auch erst diese port paranoia gehabt habe gesagt zwei ports zu aber ich komme damit klar das funktioniert super.
Muss man mitführen ne.
Den dingern also ich arbeite halt viel mit externen festplatten größeren usb-sticks und bla und ohne also meine maus habe ich auch meistens noch dran,
los gerät ja mit kabel.
Klar mit kabel.
Natürlich mit kabel.
Also ich habe an an dem dell laptop halt irgendwie drei usb-port und habe immer noch einen einen dunkel mit vier weiteren ports und das ist,
nicht immer einfach vor allem wenn du dann halt studien zwei vier zwei vier terabyte von a nach b schubsen willst das ist ein bisschen anstrengend.
Mäuse die kamera.
Mit ohne schnur.
Ja mit ohne schnur.
Ist das die von der zwei.
Bluetooth ist alles schön und gut solange bis es ja.
Für eine maus reicht es echt aus film aus reicht es aus wie ein hack brett maus und hack brett mit ohne schnur alter.
Ne das ist eine deutsche firma die heißt rock hat oder rocket wie auch immer c,
und weil ich jetzt ja auch gerade im extended homeoffice modus wieder ein bissel dem zocken verfallen bin brauchte ich meine,
und ein ordentliches mauspad und dann habe ich diesen hersteller gefunden und bin von diesem produkt sehr begeistert,
also die hat so einen sechzehntausend sensor und die fühlt sich mega präzise an also ich hatte davor so ein logitech ding was ich aus ergonomie gründen eigentlich ganz schön fand dieser maus habe ich sowas habe ich wieder so ein präzisionsgekühlt beim klick.
Link happy.
Die heißt rocket die ist auch überraschend leicht früher wollte ich immer schwere mäuse haben aber ich bin jetzt mit der.
Nee ich habe früher schon immer die metallding aus den mäusen rausgeschraubt weil sie mir zu schwer waren.
Ich suche mal ganz kurz hier moment.
Ich schaue die dann immer so schnell runter.
Ich war gerade sagen ich mache auch bei mir alle gewichte rein in der logitech.
Welche welche hast du denn.
Der link kommt in dieser sekunde copy falscher selection nicht in die firma metaebene.
Die firma freut sich auch.
Die firma freut sich auch zack die hab ich glaube ich,
das blöde ist an der dass sie erstmal so ein bisschen offensiv leuchtet das kann man aber dann auch ach so ja nee das problem ist eigentlich folgendes
man muss ja viele spiele unter windows zocken da gibt's dann so eine software wo man sich auch die led-leuchten ausstellen kann auf dem mac da leuchtet sie einfach fröhlich vor sich hin und her,
aber.
Kann man bei der logitech ausstellen.
Wie heißt denn deine maus.
Hundertzwanzig.
Wie auch immer,
aber die die die klickt sich extrem gut und bewegt sich ja ich find die gut die die fühlt sich gut an mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Naja gaming will man mit der maus machen alles andere natürlich nicht.
Ist nicht wahr das ist einfach nicht dass es einfach nicht wahr ich muss sagen ich habe in letzter zeit wieder in revival der maus bei mir erlebt weil ich,
bluetooth ist einfach sackt einfach gewaltig ich habe auch alle meine bluetooth die weißes
alle über kabel angeschlossen mittlerweile also dieses neue keyboard und trackpad und so weiter weil ich einfach diesen laden permanent laden ladezustand dieses dieser traum von von viren liste der ist einfach das ist einfach eine illusion ja.
Hast du immer noch diesen semi heck enttäuscht der mit bluetooth nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ja das kommt noch dazu dass dieser mini ist einfach die bier und der will irgendwie überhaupt nicht richtig das hat alles nochmal ein bisschen verschärft aber auch an allen meinen anderen geräten habe ich das mittlerweile so
dass ich eben die geräte die ja über lightning nicht nur geladen sondern auch direkt betrieben werden kann habe ich einfach ein kabel dran gemacht und dann
ist es einfach wie früher das funktioniert immer das ist immer da das ist nicht alle das disconnect nicht ist nicht irgendwie nicht zu sehen per pn ich und
verschwindet.
Ich habe das ja schon viele freakshow se gesagt kabel ist das einzig wahre.
Ja ist auch geiler als wlan da kannst du mir auch irgendwie erzählen was du willst es ist einfach dieser ganze weile des krams ist einfach das back to the roots back to the cape,
wir brauchen einfach verbindung und auch lte ist nicht die zukunft sondern wir wollen irgendwie glasfaser einfach.
Mobile glasfaser.
Eine maus,
ganz davon abgesehen so eine maus hat auch einfach von der haptik das hat einfach auch was ich arbeite auch extrem viel mit dem trackpad und dachte mir so das ist es schon so,
aber wenn man dann wirklich auf so eine präzise kabelgebundene maus wieder zurückkommt dann denkt man sich so war nicht alles schlecht früher.
Genau ja.
Aber das doch das sind doch auch äpfel und birnen und hermann und schraubendreher also.
Naja ich meine ich habe einen computer mit einem painting device die frage ist wie point bist du und ob du jetzt über ein trackpad point ist oder mit einer richtig geilen maus jetzt kommt letti.
Das problem ist nicht genau weil sie hat das der weiß genau,
dies ist immer die frage der aufgabe die du gerade erledigen willst nicht dass du weißt das was dir möglicherweise zu na ihr wisst schon also die aufgabe ist das problem weil wir gerade seht ich hantiere mit dem apple pencil herum und
alter warum kann man diesen scheiß apple pencil noch immer nicht auf dem iphone benutzen warum warum.
Steve jobs gesagt hat dass.
Hallo.
Es wäre so praktisch wenn man den eh gerade in der hand hat aber man hat ihn schon in der hand ja was kommt auch auf die aufgabe aus.
Dafür kann man jetzt eine maus dafür kann man jetzt eine maus auf dem ipad benutzen.
Oder ein trackpad ich habe das vorhin das erste mal geppert und ausprobiert.
Eine kabelgebundene maus.
Na ja es gibt ja das neue wie heißt es jetzt dreizehn vierzehn fünfzehn punkt irgendwas,
vor dreizehn vier genau und ipad geht jetzt auch mit maus ich hab's ein bisschen ausprobiert es war eher eine enttäuschung aber es na moment stopp stopp stopp es war interessant aber es war eine enttäuschung.
Interesse.
Ja es ist super interessant und zwar deshalb weil also was ich wirklich geil finde und was was in zukunft noch für schnappatmung sorgen könnte,
dass sie komplett davon weggekommen sind nur zu point ne also dieses ich zeige auf einen pixel und was dieser pixel für mich tun kann,
gibt er mir mehr oder weniger indirekt oder vielleicht auch erst wenn ich drauf klicke bekannt versus das betriebssystem weiß jetzt im besten fall so viel
über den inhalt dieses bildschirms
das werde ich auf irgendwas zeige dass dann sozusagen das worauf ich zeige der curser werden kann sprich wenn man über so einen button geht der auch ordentlich dem betriebssystem angemeldet wurde
dann wird halt der button gehighlightet wenn ich schon drüber gehe und das ist wirklich dass es.
Apple hat mausohr erfunden wow.
Ja das ist ja sowieso maus.
Ja sie machen es aber so apple-tv like wo das ding dann so schwabbel anfängt.
Das kommt noch dazu,
ja das ist wirklich also die animation ist super und die idee ist super und ich finde ich finde einfach diesen vorgang merkst du dann auch wieder sofort welche app scheiße programmiert sind wo das nämlich nicht funktioniert.
Ja auch die von apple.
Auch teilweise von apple und wo ich dann wiederum bisschen enttäuscht war ist ich hatte dann das mal mit dieser bluetooth maus von apple wie heißt die magic maus
als ja alles magic bei denen mittlerweile getestet und wasser als zu meiner größten frustration nicht funktioniert ist collin also du hast ja diese gesten.
Das mir auch sofort eingefallen aufgefallen.
Das fand ich so enttäuschend dass dass ich mir nur dachte so das kann,
es kann doch nicht euer ernst sein weil dann wäre das ipad sofort so sinnvoll geworden mit mit der maus weil man ein ipad kannst du heute sagen nur benutzen wenn es in reichweite ist aber ein ipad mit maus,
wo man scrollen kann ist ein,
unendlich viel nutzbringender gerät weil das kannst du dann irgendein beamer anschließend und aus der ferne bedienen und das geht halt deshalb nicht.
Vor allen dingen du kannst noch nicht mal so scrollen wie du es halt im simulator machst also wenn man so sachen programmiert dann gibt's ja diesen simulator läuft auf dem mac,
und da hast du ja nur die maus also was machst du du nimmst du schiebst die maus irgendwohin klickst und drecks dann und dann scrollt er natürlich aber das macht jetzt dieses ding auf dem ipad erstmal noch nicht,
noch nach.
Ja
Da müssen wir nach nach.
Peak apple.
Ja aber aber das ipad sozusagen fernbedienung ne weil das ist mit diesem ganzen touch ist das ja einfach abhanden gekommen fernbedienung gibt es irgendwie nicht auf ipads alles nur nah bedienung,
du benutzt die ganze zeit nur die narbe dehnung und es macht mich wahnsinnig dass das finde ich ja so geil also das sind denen einfach auch aus der ferne bedienen kannst sogar aus dem internet ferne kannst du den bedienen das ist ganz toll.
Ja das ist auch so ein korona ding.
Ja das ist nicht corona kompatibel,
naja läuft um nochmal bei apple zu bleiben wie findet ihr denn das ding mit der online worldwide konferenz und was ist eure erwartungen was dort passieren wird.
Meine erste frage was ist denn der preis jetzt dafür steht da jetzt irgendwas drin ich habe das letzte mal nichts gefunden.
Es sind noch überhaupt keine preise es gibt auch noch keine termine sie haben nur gesagt wird online sein wird euch die möglichkeit geben eine keynote anzuschauen talks anzuschauen und es gibt auch die möglichkeit mit
ihr geilen engineers zu interaction oder wie sie das genannt haben typischerweise zahlst jan konferenz preis der ist nicht ganz niedrig und dann musst du
mal.
Sieben oder so.
Ja dann musst du noch mal das dreifache in flug und vor allem hotel und was nicht alles investieren also daran teilzunehmen es ohnehin schon ziemlich teuer und dann.
Für die meisten war es jetzt schon eine online-konferenz ich spreche aus erfahrung was soll schon groß anders sein sie machen die talks irgendwie nehmen die auf und stellen sie online was soll da groß passieren.
Oh ich rechne ehrlich gesagt mit größeren änderungen also da wird einiges passieren weil sie werden ja.
Also ich glaube ich glaube dass sie das schon länger in der pipeline hatten.
Ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt für dieses jahr und dass sie.
Nicht für dieses jahr aber es war klar dass sowieso klar dass sich was ändern muss weil diese beschränkung auf weiß ich nicht wie viel tausende,
developer halt auch einfach nie funktioniert hat in den letzten zehn jahren und na ja müssen wir gucken aber ich glaube nicht dass es online was kosten wird es sei denn man will jetzt tatsächlich fragen an irgendwelche engineers stellen,
ich glaube so wird das laufen.
Genau und das das.
Die frage ist laut buchen kannst und dann zahlst du dafür geld und dann kannst du deine frage stellen und fertig.
Genau das denke ich auch dass es kommen wird und ich hoffe halt dass sie dann eben in dem zuge auch mal ihre ganzen online-tools wie fiesta mit cetera
entweder aufpoppen dass da sozusagen mehr corona features drin sind ne so also screen sharing keine ahnung slideshow keynote integration pipapo sie haben ja im prinzip alles es ist halt.
Zehn fünfzehn corona.
Genau das das wärs ne fünfzehn haben wir doch schon oder nicht,
wechseln.
Nicht sogar sechzehn schon draußen.
Zehn zehn zehn zehn sechzehn carola und na ja ich meine das ist doch jetzt die herausforderung da man man kann auch sozusagen heutzutage als computer hersteller gar nicht mehr bestehen wenn man nicht pandemien fest ist,
und alles muss sozusagen auch in der apokalypse noch funktionieren können und einen sinnvollen beitrag dazu leisten können sie auch zehn punkt sechzehn apokalypse genau nennen,
und so.
So ein ort gibt es bestimmt auch.
Ja
und dann dann willst du halt richtigen kollaborationen tools haben und dann wird es auch mit der maus scrollen können auf dem ipad also damit sozusagen alles irgendwie aus der ferne machen und ich denke dass das das wird jetzt bei vielen leuten klicken das,
im prinzip die vollständige arbeitszimmers,
oder kollaborations-ideen version über internet das ist unser ziel also alles andere kann ja jetzt sozusagen überhaupt gar keine rolle mehr spielen auf diesem planeten du willst einfach.
Naja wir könnten noch die arbeitsbedingungen für alle anderen die nicht remote arbeiten könnten verbessern.
Klar aber alles im sinne von das also alles was ich
was ich für homeoffice zieren lassen kann ja soll dann sozusagen auch gut funktionieren,
gar keine frage aber sicherlich gibt es auch in anderen berufen dinge wo die leute sich immer gefragt haben muss ich dafür jetzt wirklich aufstehen oder kann ich das ja auch von zu hause aus machen
weiterbildung zum beispiel im allgemeinen das ist natürlich so ein thema muss halt auch immer irgendwohin rennen viel zeiten straßenbahn verbringen et cetera und das wäre eine ganz elegante methode mal unsere ganzen verkehrs
runterzubringen ich hoffe ja dass demnächst nicht mehr so viel geflogen wird.
Das problem kann sich auch von alleine lösen.
Durch die abwehr ablehnung der menschheit mal so jetzt.
Durch die ablehnung der airlines.
Achso der airlines ja das vielleicht auch schauen wir mal aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei der w w c es gibt jetzt vielleicht nicht so viel her aber ich finde diesen gedanken ganz gut überhaupt mal drüber nachzudenken,
was könnte denn ein onlinetool leisten ich meine das können wir jetzt auch mal kombinieren mit dem problem was wir jetzt hier haben also so man kommt zusammen man will gemeinsame dinge tun und jetzt schon mal so allein so ein bildschirm zu scheren ist schon mal so ein problem,
also geht irgendwie so ein bisschen aber dann musste ich jetzt einen anderen rechner nehmen und da.
Wusstest du nicht.
Doch musste ich weil ich konnte ja.
Du wolltest ja nur der eine komische fratze gleichzeitig mit brotkasten aber ansonsten sehe ich die ganze zeit ein bildschirm super in qualität und lesbar und schick und schön.
Ja weil ich einen zweiten computer genommen habe du kannst jetzt nicht auf dem ding rum klicken und du wir können da nicht irgendwelche.
Mach doch natürlich kannst du dann rumklicken klicks ja die ganze zeit auf dem bildschirm rum.
Ja ich aber du nicht.
Man sieht nur ein preview bild das nicht.
Du siehst nur was ich da anzeige aber wir haben kein chat workspace da ist jetzt irgendwie kein kein whiteboard wir können hier keine sticky notes machen wir haben
gut den chat haben wir jetzt vielleicht hier irgendwie mit drin aber von kollaboration ist das noch weit entfernt können keine dateien teilen wir können ja nicht irgendwie.
Ich kann ja mal eine datei auf den kopf ziehen,
gucken was da passiert.
Ja wahrscheinlich nichts wahrscheinlich geht ein bild dann weg und dein browser sagte er dass er das pdf nicht anzeigen kann oder so.
Bei uns im büro versuchen wir uns ja auch an verschiedensten tools gefühlt jede woche ein neues jetzt gerade fand ich aber eins ganz interessant clemens disconnect.
Genau was ich gesagt habe.
Sehr schön.
Siehst du auch nur im audio.
Und zwar heißt das tandem das tool,
und bei tandem kannst du dir das ist im prinzip wie so ein virtuelles büro das heißt dass du kannst also raume anlegen und es ist so voice und video-chat und screen sharing und du kannst einfach so,
einen raum heißt watercolor oder coffee maschine wo sich dann die leute einfach so zum schnacken treffen du kannst einfach ohne groß joint call oder zeremonie
einfach nur mit klicken auf den raum rein und raus und da kann man auch auswählen welche videostudio,
technologie man benutzen möchte und der deal ist glaube ich auch gisi bei denen tatsächlich das fand ich zumindest ganz so.
Demnächst gibt's da ein virtuelles lab.
Was was heißt nochmal lab.
Live-action roll play du kannst halt damit so ein office simulieren und dann hast du.
Ja ja ja genau genau ich.
Looping wo leute office personen spielen.
Genau ich packe den link mal in den chat und da kannst du dann auch falls scheren und dann gibt's irgendwie noch integration in diverseste tools ich finde das interface ein bisschen,
naja sagen wir mal so verwirrend und auch so ein paar defaulteinstellungen fragwürdig aber das konzept fand ich zumindest erstmal ganz gut um sozusagen was tim gerade schon,
an moderierte als wunsch irgendwie ein bisschen mehr interaktion zu machen und dadurch dass jetzt auch noch da als die volt video-chat hatten war es mir nicht ganz unsympathisch.
Ja also da wird sich jetzt sicherlich was tun aber natürlich muss ich gerade apple auch fragen wie kriegen sie das in ihrer in ihre gesamte experience mit rein weil es hängt ja dann immer sehr viel von den details ab.
Ich meine der kongress war ja jetzt eh schon vorne mit dabei mit kongress everywhere wenn sich das jetzt noch so lange hinzieht dann kann man wirklich kongress everywhere machen.
Ging doch heute schon schon rum ich muss mal gucken ob ich wieder finde.
Die leute haben was geschrieben.
Genau also drei bock hat sowieso schon ein paar tutorials was man so machen kann und und sollte.
Im bezug auf fast konferenzen online.
Konferenzen online machen und die wollen halt mal gucken ich muss.
Aber mehr im sinne von dem machen was der was der was der club sowieso schon jetzt immer macht mit wir streben unsere vorträge ich meine könnt ihr euch das vorstellen ein kongress online.
Also nur wenn es da auch den späti gibt.
Ist halt was anderes,
also gerade mit so mit so virtuellen treffpunkten kann ich mir das schon vorstellen weil normalerweise also man dass das schöne am kongress ist ja dass man so so
und mit leuten connecten kann mit denen man sonst nicht connected oder halt irgendwie lust hat und wenn man tatsächlich so eine virtuellen anlaufpunkte hat wo man einfach
dann auch in die gruppe reinkommen würde finde ich das schon interessant mir persönlich würden da reichen weil ich halt lieber,
tippe als rede aber das lässt sich ja alles beliebig kombinieren.
Du weißt dass du in einem podcast bist.
Ich weiß auch dass ich mich lange dagegen gewehrt habe können wir einen chat podcast machen.
Toll.
Aber also ich würde schon sagen ich das beim kongress auch für mich eher mittlerweile so familientreffen charakter hat also das ist mein eigentliches weihnachtsferien treffen gefühlt,
insofern glaube ich nicht dass das eine reine online virtuelle experience jetzt so vom gefühl her ersetzen kann aber da ja natürlich der kongress nicht nur familientreffen ist sondern auch,
wissenswertes teilung und wissensvermittlung der teil der geht online sicherlich.
Also ich glaube dass ein teil des kongresses da funktioniert das besser als bei vielen anderen veranstaltungen und bei einem anderen teil des kongresses funktioniert's halt gar nicht glaube ich,
dieser ganze irrsinn der da passiert den man mitkriegt indem man durch hallen läuft den kann ich mir das kann ich mir online nicht vorstellen dass das dass das geht.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt schon irgendwie immer mit dem also ich bin ja ich werde ja mit leipzig nicht so ganz warm als kongress location weil es einfach so als ein,
ja weil's einfach so 'ne so 'ne messe fehling hat und es wird es auch nie loswerden glaube ich und ich wünsche mir nichts sehnlicher als dass wir wieder nach hamburg zurückkehren aber insofern wenn jetzt
also wenn es mit corona sich noch so weit ausweitet dass der jetzt auch virtuell stattfinden muss dann wäre ich gar nicht so traurig dieses jahr vielleicht nicht nach leipzig zu müssen.
Du musst per se nicht nach leipzig es zwingt dich niemand aus.
Ich weiß aber da sind.
Erfurt fahren.
Aber da sind schon auch die ganzen netten leute nur ich glaube.
Aber ich denke mir das nochmal ein bisschen anders was ist denn sozusagen also was leistet eine konferenz konferenz leistet,
und zwar gar nicht mal nur der kongress aber beim kongress ist es ähnlich leistet eigentlich im wesentlichen auf zwei achsen etwas es gibt eine,
üblicherweise mehr oder weniger frontale wissensvermittlung durch kooperation ausgewählte talks das,
führt dann zu einem gewissen agenda setting man definiert sozusagen die themen man man setzt damit auch die folge diskussion ein wenig und dann hat man eben dieses treffen in gruppen,
dieses kennenlernen einander vorstellen miteinander reden mal über irgendwas quatschen,
was du natürlich online glaube ich nie so richtig repliziert bekommen wirst ist natürlich so dieses,
unmittelbare nähe spüren auf der einen seite und natürlich dass du auch eine einschätzung weil deine privatsphäre machen kannst,
was halt auf dem kongress auch nicht unbedingt immer einfach ist aber wenn er irgendwo in der ecke steht dann weißt du schon wo du bist.
Und einfach der punkt halt des connecten so total verschaltet durch den kongress streifen mit irgendwelchen leuten im schlepptau auf andere leute treffen plötzlich feststellen dass ich irgendwie alle irgendwie über drei ecken kennen und beste freunde werden und so das,
das passiert online glaube ich einfach nicht dann.
Also ich habe ja ich habe ja schon mal ich habe ja sowas schon mal programmiert,
und das ist schon achtundzwanzig jahre her und das hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert ja also in der ja in der villa haben sich leute getroffen und da war einfach die soziale interaktion aber richtig hallo mein.
Zwar dit war sehr.
Das war audio und die leute haben sich danach geheiratet also das hat jetzt so schlecht nicht funktioniert ja also nicht alle aber einige haben sich,
tatsächlich dort kennen das war halt facebook chat twitter sitzi und,
kinder in heimen irgendwie und die leute haben sich da klingelt man es war natürlich auch eine zeit der totale abwesenheit des internets es gab es halt einfach nicht mehr als nur per telefon
stattfand aber trotzdem haben die leute sich dort gefunden man man hat irgendwie seine gemütlichen ecken
gefunden man konnte sich in den kühlschrank zurückziehen aber man nur zu zweit und ähnliche geschichten wie auch im darm klum übrigens und am klub passen auch nur zwei rein.
Und das in zeiten in prag flatrate zeiten die leute mussten damals echt noch minuten gebühren bezahlen.
Richtig da sogar das normale ortsgespräch noch ordentlich geld gekostet und die leute die von außen aus dem sogenannten naht tarif telefonieren mussten oder sogar dem fernen tarif die mussten schon richtig abplatzen und trotzdem hat wunderbar funktioniert also es hat
nicht lange gedauert und da waren irgendwie dreißig bis sechzig leute permanent online ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so groß rum
posen was damals für tolle sachen gemacht habe also das ist natürlich auch aber nicht primär.
Wollen wir den scheiß nicht nur.
Die erkenntnis.
Und irgendwie ein sieb connector dran machen.
Ja mal gucken also jetzt ist das hat das vielleicht sogar wieder konjunktur ein gewisser hinsicht war das ja auch so eine art live-podcast wo man dann mitmachen konnte,
was ich nur daraus ableiten wollte ist.
So audio funktionalitäten auf der einen seite also das man natürlich auch video also dass man sich sozusagen zusammen konferenz ziehen kann aber eben auch dieses abbilden von,
tipps geben leute vorstellen et cetera also ross irgendwie alles in allem so ein bisschen so linkedin mit videokonferenz und raum,
dass du wirklich auch über so einen virtuellen raum marschieren kannst man in der villa konnte halt
irgendwo hingehen und dadurch dass du dich an diesen raum gegeben hast hast du eben auch schon kommuniziert wie du jetzt gerade drauf bist und so ist es ja auch auf dem kongress wenn du hinten
was weiß ich wenn ein vortrag geht dann willst du halt still und in ruhe gelassen werden und hörst ja halt irgendwas an
wenn du im flur rum stehst dann bist du halt potenziell schonmal ansprechbar wenn er hinten zu einer bar gehst dann wird es mit der ansprechbarkeit noch ein bisschen größer und dann hast du noch irgendwie dahinten die lounge und den dancefloor und was nicht alles und et cetera pp und so ähnlich müsste man wahrscheinlich so ein kongress auch nachbilden also man müsste wirklich den,
schaffen ein bisschen ort nachbilden und natürlich gäbe es dann auch den späti bei dem man an vielleicht nicht wirklich ein bier kriegt aber halt,
keine ahnung genau kriegst du auf jeden fall punk.
Kriegt man auf jeden fall ja tja aber auf der wc wird's wahrscheinlich kein späti geben.
Da gibt's kein später aber da gab es ja auch schon vorher kein späti von daher keinen verlust,
gut wir können das thema ist sicher ist inspiriert euch nicht so einstellen,
ich wollte noch ein paar sonstige kleine sachen die ich noch entdeckt habe nochmal reinschmeißen das wird auch noch ganz kurz nur,
und zwar wollte ich nochmal von meinem lieblingsprogram benutze bericht von einem meiner lieblingsprogram berichten nämlich money money,
ihr wisst schon das tolle online-banking tool geht's ja auch wieder wichtig und.
Seit wann das geld wieder wichtig.
Die meisten leute es nicht.
Jetzt neu geld ist wieder wichtig ich habe ich habe nur ein paar kleinigkeiten,
entdeckt und zwar habe ich ja vor einiger zeit habe ich ja mal diesen apple pay button,
auf meiner meterebene spendenseite eingebaut und das fand ich ja irgendwie schon ganz bemerkenswert dass das überhaupt funktioniert das
klappt also quasi auf allen geräten die unmittelbare apple pay anbindung haben also natürlich auf so einem iphone
wo halt apple pay account konfiguriert ist kann man dann quasi direkt über die website das auslösen aber es geht halt auch auf dem mac wohne apple watch,
geperrten ist also aus sogar auf meinem alten macbook ohne touch id kann ich halt apple pay benutzen weil ich ja mit meiner uhr verbunden bin und dann kann ich
darüber sozusagen das machen
das war ich schon mal ganz bemerkenswert auf jeden fall war's gar nicht so schwierig das einzubauen ich musste mich aber eines bands bedienen in dem fall nämlich stripe,
hallo
die dann letzten endes das ganze peyman prozesse machen sprich wenn jetzt jemand sagt so hier mit der ebene passt schon irgendwie da gebe ich mal was und dann apple watch rausziehen und man überweist mal fünf euro dann über erreicht mich das sozusagen.
Über stripe
und jetzt ist ja stripe so wieder so ein obscura zahlungsanbieter im internet und ich habe immer so ein bisschen meine probleme mit irgendwelchen diensten die so geld rum rauten und dann auf anderen kanälen zu mir durchschieben
und ich habe da keine unmittelbaren konnten digitalen konnten einblick stellt sich raus
jemand hat für stripe schon so eine extension gebaut für money money und ich kann tatsächlich dass wie so ein normales bankkonto einbauen also falls irgendjemand von euch mit stripe.
Sachen abrechnet man kann das in money money reinbekommen und ich habe auch schon back gefixt in dem in dem modul weil da war nämlich einer drin,
leider reagiert der mentaltrainer nicht mehr ich habe ihm eine mail geschrieben ich werd's auch vielleicht nochmal probieren falls du doch noch lebst bitte melde dich ich hab da ich hab da ein buch
fix für dein modul ansonsten werde ich gleich mal mein meine meine gitarre entsprechend verlinken wo das sozusagen schon
gefixt ist und das funktioniert soweit ganz super das heißt ich kann
all diese ganzen zahlungen auch direkt in meinem buchungsdatum bums sehen und das benutzen wir jedes konto auch und als ich dann in diesem kleinen
extension universum noch ein bisschen rumgeblättert habe ist mir noch was anderes geiles aufgefallen und das dürfte für euch alle die falls ihr den manni manni verwendet auch ganz interessant sein und zwar hat jemand nämlich ein amazon.
Plugin geschrieben für mandy mandy und ich dachte so was wie amazon sind die jetzt auch eine bank nein,
aber man kann sozusagen alle seine amazon bestellung die man jemals gemacht hat,
auch direkt in manni manni einfach reinbekommen und hat das erste mal quasi so eine offline kopie aller
käufe die man jemals gemacht hat und ihr kennt dieses problem mit ich habe doch da mal was bei amazon bestellt was was war denn das nochmal und man kriegt das nicht geladen und dann die webseite und dann wo ist denn das und klick hier und tralala und dann findet man vielleicht irgendwann jetzt kann man einfach dieses kleine
amazon plugin direkt in deinem money money rein speisen hat
seine komplette bestell- historie bis dumme malz direkt in money money und kann dann auch noch selber wählen wie das auftaucht ob das so als plus minus oder plus und minus beträge aufgeführt werden soll,
ganz toll großartig sowie dazu.
Totale begeisterung ja manchmal ist toll.
Ist auch toll abgesehen davon dass es nicht richtig filtern kann das nervt ohne ende.
Was machst du damit.
Na ja es geht nicht also man muss irgendwie regional express schreiben das ist broken.
Der muss regeln wer muss man regelrecht expresso schreiben.
Na ja wenn du willst dass er irgendwas automatisch filtert musste regal expression schreiben und damit es.
Immerhin kann man regler entsprechend benutzen.
Wo kann man den regeln entsprechend schreiben.
Für zivilisten ist sie durch aber für profis ist das geil wünschte ich mir dass diese dusseligen suchfunktion in irgendwelchen programmen oder webseiten standardmäßig regeln unterstützen würden.
Warte mal du willst mir gerade sagen dass money money regionalexpress in dem suchst trinken unterstützt ernsthaft.
In den filtern auf jeden fall also in diesem auto kategorie dings das ich weiß nicht ob's generell oben in der suche geht.
Allein schon deswegen sollte diese programm jetzt.
Der normalen suche geht das nicht was weißt du denn mit filtern.
Na wenn du da links in einer zeit war deine kategorien auto befüllt ist irgendwie was ich tanken finanzamt.
Ach so das meinst du dieses automatische zuweisen von kategorien hotty oder was.
Genau das ist alles ein bisschen broken das ist irgendwie das macht keinen spaß.
Was genau macht es keinen spaß das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Die regeln für die automatische kategorisierung anzulegen das ist einfach painful.
Achso ja okay gut ne da geht einiges besser aber ich habe die letzten tage ein paar bugfixes durchgedrückt bekommen die ich ein paar feature request durchgedrückt bekommen die ich vor einem halben jahr mal gestellt habe und bitten insofern gerade ganz happy customer.
Weißt du für mich ist für mich ist das feature eine blinkende null wie man so schön sagt ne also das das kennst du das denn.
Nee überhaupt nicht blicken wir neu.
Das ist die leute die ein videorekorder haben wo die null blinkt weil die uhr einzustellen viel zu kompliziert ist also lassen sie es einfach bleiben für mich ist das eine blinkende null dieses feature ist es mir zu,
ja mit dem filtern gibts irgend so 'ne obskure filter sprache und mit reggae expression alles irgendwie brocken.
Also ich verstehe dein schmerz nicht ganz bei mir also ich hatte bisher damit keine probleme.
Ich auch nicht ich benutze das nur ich kriege alles zugeordnet damit.
Finde ich auch super.
Vielleicht muss rolli mal 'n youtube-video.
Mehr videotutorials.
Hey ronny kein problem ich mache den video-tutorial ey ich ich mache jetzt nicht mehr.
Tories tim.
Tutorial.
Auf der muss das.
Genau korona begründet meine zweite große karriere mal gucken,
naja auf jeden fall falls irgendjemand von euch da auch der meinung ist man könnte ohne moni moni und online-banking irgendwie leben vergesst es einfach ja es ist einfach es geht aber nicht dass wenn wenn du das gemacht habt,
danach einfach alles besser,
und demnächst gibt's ein paar schöne bugfixes auf die ich mich schon aufs release freue ich bin ja hier irgendwie immer auf der beta und so und dann wird alles gut,
okay next haben wir noch tim eine menge ne.
Was nicht du hattest du hattest bei dem bei dem apple thema das neue ipad ganz ausgeklammert aber es vielleicht auch nicht wichtig dass es ein neues ipad gibt oder.
Na so neu ist es ja eigentlich nicht ich meine alles was sie da drinnen neu haben ist ja eigentlich nur dieses lieder laser dingsbums und da muss man mal gucken was es kann.
Leader laser und diese tastatur die ist erst im mai gibt mit trackpad.
Ja das schauen wir uns glaube ich mal an wenn es das irgendwie alles gibt bis dahin ist es eigentlich eher uninteressant würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Ja die
du du hast aber noch was schönes was ich neulich aus unserem podcast rausgeschnitten habe als wir über deine krankheit
gesprochen haben das dachte ich mir passt aber wunderbar in die freakshow und das vielleicht auch nochmal so ein bisschen als corona support an dieser stelle weil wir haben ja alle immer jetzt sozusagen dieses problem mit oh gott was mache ich jetzt mit meiner ganzen heimen freizeit
gut ich weiß wir haben dieses problem nicht wirklich aber die anderen leute haben dieses problem und die schau dir aber gerne filme und ich war jetzt zum beispiel gerade bei,
bei max schneider zu gast und habe im film,
podcast mal über mein lieblingsfilm gesprochen was ganz unterhaltsam geworden ist glaube ich nämlich brasil,
oder kam natürlich dann als das verkündet habe sofort die frage ja wo läuft denn das eigentlich und zu dem zeitpunkt kannte ich das schon aber offensichtlich könnte das noch nicht jeder deswegen erwähne ich dass man es gibt dieses schöne webseite wer streamt,
und auf wer stream punkt kann man auf spanisch genau.
Eine spanische webseite.
Eine spanische domain aber eine deutsche webseite und na ja da kann man dann einfach den film eintragen die man gerne haben möchte wie zum beispiel brasil
kriegt er so eine liste und dann sagt er einem so ok gibt es jetzt gerade bei amazon prime als teil der flatrate oder kannst du dir auf folgenden plattformen anschauen für folgende preise
also wenn ihr keinen bock habt wie ich nämlich immer so einfach nur so der büttel des geklickten streaming dienstes zu sein weil ihr wollt einfach,
einen film schauen und ihr seid auch bereit gegebenenfalls geld dafür zu investieren oder ihr wollt zumindest mal darauf hingewiesen werden welcher laden wo ihr sowieso schon geld investiert den euch jetzt auch kostenlos
hervorbringen würde dann kann man unter anderem da nachschauen ich glaube es gibt auch noch ein paar andere plattformen dieser art über die.
Zu sagen es ist mal wieder unglaublich verdinglicht verdinglicht wurde der wer streamt es schreiben sie mit tee statt mit idee hinten.
Na ja macht ja nix.
Und für die zwei domain mit idee hat's nicht erreicht.
Wer streamt ja ich finde das ist so richtig geschrieben ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist englisch.
Natürlich ist das englische stream ist englisch.
Ja ist es sehr.
Du es gerne wer strömt ist.
Streamt wie das englische wort streamt.
Na wenn schon strömen nee dann.
Aber dann ist der vergangenheit.
Dann ist es ja dann heißt es ja strömte also das.
Streaming egal aber dieses egal schön.
Dass du bist doppelt falsch jetzt sozusagen,
und dann hast du noch ein anderes tool genannt deswegen kann ich jetzt gerade drauf rudi nämlich dieses v i d e oder windel.
Genau.
Und das ist wirklich das ist wirklich nice also ihr kennt ja sicherlich alle,
youtube dsl das command light tool was öfter mal genannt wird wenn es darum geht mal ja sich eigentlich nur so streamen oder zumindest video on-demand mäßig anbietende videoinhalte,
wenn man die mal.
Also mein mein mein favorit youtube clint nenne ich's immer.
Youtube de genau das ist toll weil als youtube de taugt eben anders als der name impliziert nicht nur für youtube
sondern er funktioniert auch ganz wunderbar mit vielen anderen videoplattformen auch so mediathek,
auch ard arte et cetera also im prinzip kann man eigentlich
jede url wurden video ist alpha auf youtube drauf schmeißen weil selbst wenn er die plattform nicht kennt kennt ihr das hatte durch guckt ob da irgendwo so ein offensichtlicher ich bin das video link ist und versucht
aus den metadaten alles heraus zu hauen und man kann eigentlich das allermeiste damit irgendwie runterladen und jetzt.
Ich würde sogar sagen es ist schwer was zu finden was es nicht runterladen kann also selbst ich wollte letztens ein video aus einem tweet extrem auf twitter dot com geht das jetzt auch nicht mehr so einfach und das findet er auch also ich,
jede dich da mit dem video gegen gefeiert habe hat eigentlich immer ergebnisse geliefert.
Was ist mit sachen wo du dich erst einloggen musst.
Da musst du dich dann musst du noch einen cookie irgendwie mit rüber reichen oder so keine ahnung.
Also also bei bei bei deutschen öffentlich-rechtlichen mediatheken wird's manchmal schwierig aber aber auch da bin ich schon erfolgreich gewesen.
So aber jetzt gibt's ja leute die können ja mit command kleines nicht so richtig klar kommen weil es irgendwie alles viel zu schwierig und viel zu schwarz und so und viel zu viel,
und dafür gibt es vor mac und strich software punkt com slash und das ist im prinzip so 'ne art youtube de clint zum klicken,
und hat nicht nur den vorteil dass du da einfach eine url eintragen kannst und ein liter das für dich runter nein es gibt sogar ein safari extension und ich weiß nicht aber andere browser auch noch unterstützt.
Ich glaube schon aber ich weiß es nicht genau und dann hat man den button wo man nur noch drauf drückt wenn man auf der seite ist.
Es gibt eine safari.
Das heißt das könnte auch das login thema denn lösen vielleicht.
Das kann.
Dass man sich mit safari erst einloggt und dann.
Sein weil sie nicht ganz genau auf jeden fall kriegst du dann eben kannst du eben mal schnell zack zack zack runterladen runterladen runterladen also das ist dann sozusagen auch für leute die nicht ganz so gängig sind mit command line.
Ja vor allen dingen er packt alles in der liste rein und und arbeitet die dann auch im hintergrund ab bei bei youtube de musste ja immer warten bis er fertig ist mit seinem kommando zahlen prozessen dann kannst du einen neuen starten.
Der trend geht zum zeitfenster rudi.
Hallo.
Ich weiß aber wenn der trend beim ein dutzend fenstern ist dann wird's langsam unhandlich.
Dann benutzt du screen oder wie huckel sagen würde next.
Ach ja gut.
Also ist jetzt nicht ist jetzt kein tool was man unbedingt braucht aber ich fand's bis jetzt ganz praktisch.
Es ist es ist ein schönes ding auf jeden fall.
Ich kenne auf jeden fall auch einige leute die mack haben den ich immer sage auf die frage wie sie denn das mal runterladen könnten und so dann youtube de und ein terminal dann schalten sie sofort dann klappen die rollläden runter und die augen drehen einmal im kreis.
So schwierig ist das kann ja auch verstehen.
Aber es ist genau das übrigens meine frage mit dem login beantwortet vor ideal dadurch dass sie auch ein kleinen mini browser mitliefern und dann benutze den halt einfach um dich dort einzuloggen,
da nimmt er dann alle cookies und alles mit was man braucht um dann auf login-seite zeugs runterzuladen,
das ist genau das tool was ich suchte.
Hallo.
Na na na.
Schön.
Diese diese das soll freakshow ist mal durchaus fruchtvolle.
Kannst du auch noch was lernen.
Mal sagen tja und noch einen sendung titel wir hatten ein paar schöne sendung.
Daran mangelt es uns derzeit nicht so richtig genau so war durch mit unseren themen zwanzig minuten vor schluss.
Welchen wochentag haben wir eigentlich.
Sonntag.
Ne die wichtigste frage ist wer hat was nebenbei gemacht.
Was haben wir alle nebenbei gemacht.
Jetzt wo man in ruhe zu hause sind.
Korrupter um konfigurieren wie sonst in der freakshow was ging heute nicht hatte ich keine lust.
Mensch mensch mensch.
Schön schön so.
Ich habe ich habe nur bier nebenher getrunken wie eigentlich immer also diesmal sogar mehr weil ich nicht mehr im auto da bin sondern zuhause.
Tim ich glaube das fokus reitest kauf ich dir ab ich finde es gut,
dummerweise meint mein mein apple pädagoge ich kann dir nicht mit meiner apple pay per per message irgendwelche geld überweisen das heißt ich muss jetzt irgendwie auf irgendwelche webseiten gehen und.
Das geht in deutschland noch nicht ne.
Okay gut dann würden wir doch mal irgendwie mal eine iban oder sowas über den zaun.
Ja ja das machen wir mal alles offline also wir machen's online aber offline hier vom rest gut wollen wir schluss machen oder habt ihr noch irgendwas schönes beizutragen ich bin so ein bisschen im team mit themen.
Ja also von mir aus können wir auch erstmal die erste remote jetzt ausklingen lassen und das experiment bei gegebenen zeitpunkt wiederholen,
bei nachlassen der wirkung die anwälte.
Der moment moment ich sehe eine gehobene hand beziehungsweise angehobenen marker stift.
Textmarker was ich nur ganz interessant und lustig fand noch im zuge von von corona es gab ja damals pokemon go,
als großes community,
damals themen was halt auch immer noch viel gespielt wird die haben tatsächlich ihre spielmechanismen grundlegend geändert so dass leute besser von zu hause spielen können und nicht mehr in gruppen durch die gegend hatten.
Was war doch gleich der grund also ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber die haben in spanien glaube ich einen zweiundsiebzigjährige weiß nicht ob ihr eine strafe zahlen musst oder ob sie ihn verhaften wollten weil da draußen nachts pokemon go.
Ich weiß nicht ob's bei dem einen aber alleine durch asien.
In dem zug habe ich das nämlich gehört und ich dachte mir so wort.
Ja alleine durch asien haben die halt im prinzip umgestellt und dieses niantic macht jetzt auch irgendwie harry potter ding und so und das fand ich halt noch ganz ganz cool und spannend,
dass auch da eher anreize getroffen werden zu hause zu bleiben.
Aber was haben sie denn da geändert du musst jetzt nicht du musst jetzt nicht mehr rumrennen oder was das ganze spiel ist sozusagen kaputt.
Genau genau genau so,
die spielmechanismen ist eine ähnliche du hast aber andere community mechaniken also du kannst zum beispiel dann online gegen freunde spielen sachen machen.
Musst du jetzt öfter mal aufstehen taler vielleicht wäre das was für dich.
Mein mein pokémon ist auf der switch da muss ich mich nicht bewegen.
Der versuch war es wert.
Ja das fand ich nur ganz schön vielleicht kann man halt wirklich so irgendwie andere spielmechanismen noch übertragen und auf seine art und weise die welt besser machen.
So wie wir das jetzt hier auch probieren neue spielmechanismen für die freakshow mal gucken wir lassen das mal die hörer bewerten ob das funktioniert hat oder nicht okay.
Ich finde den lack auf pizza noch ein bisschen erschreckend aber das kriegen wir noch hin na ja normalerweise gibt's ja immer.
Findet ihr jetzt eigentlich dann die tonspuren schicken.
Nö wahrscheinlich nicht das hat ja alles ganz wunderbar funktioniert ich habe keine aussetzer festgehalten also hat alles ganz top funktioniert obwohl.
Ich habe am anfang hast du so ein bisschen geruckelt und so aber wie ist das wie ist das das studiolink das hat jetzt hier so ein fall mir irgendwo auf die platte geschrieben und das wird jetzt auch nicht gelöscht wenn ich das nicht löschen.
Richtig das liegt in deinem home-studio link und da locker punkt flagge und das kannst du ja vielleicht erstmal alles noch soweit belassen genau
alright.
Aufgenommen hast.
Dann denken danken danke wir an alle da draußen die durchgehalten haben ich weiß es jetzt relativ viel ausgefallen und deswegen haben wir uns jetzt hier auch zusammengerauft und das alles mal demotiviert jetzt müssen wir mal schauen welche,
zyklus wir anstreben weil es gab ja schon noch ein paar sendungen die ich schon fertig geplant hatte die die jetzt auch alle ausfallen mussten
unter anderem wollte ich demnächst mal den ralf hier dazu holen,
weil ja im podcast bereich gerade ganz viel passiert ist mit dem neuen ultraschall et cetera ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen aber ich mache jetzt mal noch keine versprechung das muss man nochmal ein bisschen bequatschen dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen,
öfter freakshow machen aber dann eben thematisch mehr fokussiert das sehen wir dann da weil die ausrede ich kann nicht vorbeikommen die gibt's ja jetzt nicht mehr.
Übrigens die ausrede ich habe hier bloß fünf stühle und auf einem sitz ich gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Tja so sieht's aus.
Nur so nebenbei tim,
aber jetzt mal jetzt mal zu dir mal wie hast du warst ja mal der der mega skeptiker der mir gesagt hat nee man kann das nicht machen weil es fühlt halt anders oder ist nicht so geil ich klar ist jetzt anders aber war denn jetzt für dich okay so vom gefühl her,
fang fühlen.
Du dich denn jetzt so.
Genau wie fühlst du dich denn jetzt so.
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht nicht nicht so so schlecht aber das hat jetzt auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun dass wir alle online sind,
meine skepsis ist sozusagen immer gewesen dass wenn einer oder zwei nicht,
vor ort sind dass es dass es dann umkippt wenn wir alle online sind ist es ist es ein bisschen was anderes und von daher.
Sehr valides argument ja okay.
Das kenne ich das kenne ich vom remote arbeiten wenn man der einzige ist der remote ist dann geht es so gut wie gar nicht.
So also insofern bleibe ich einfach mal weiter ich mache meinen punkt mit man man muss schon irgendwie auf demselben level sein und da sind wir halt jetzt in gewisser,
genau das ist das ist immer ganz gut wir können das jetzt mal ausprobieren ob das sozusagen auch noch mit gästen funktioniert weil es auf jeden fall auch nochmal ein faktor ob man eingespielt ist und da sind wir in gewisser hinsicht auch
ja und dann schauen wir einfach mal.
Erst mal so ein profi wie ralf nehmen da ist es ja auch technisch zumindestens denke ich mal kein problem und dann kannst du mal zivilisten einladen.
Geh.
Oh
Da wir werden jetzt wir werden jetzt einfach deutschland mit werde ich es mit headsets bespielen es hat sich auf jeden fall ausgezahlt dass ich so in den letzten zeit immer wieder bin auf ebay mal eins meiner lieblingshotels auftauchte
und sich das für eine halbwegs brauchbar den preis kaufen ließ habe ich dann geschlagen sodass ich jetzt immer noch drei,
fest installierte headsets hier im studio habe und noch vier,
fünf über habe für beschickung also geht noch was jetzt muss ich nur noch.
Land verschlickung.
Genau jetzt muss ich nur noch das ding mit dem audiointerface noch checken und dann.
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes bei mir.
Gucken wir mal wie das so läuft vielleicht ist ja dieses ei track solo was das klicke ich mir jetzt erstmal.
So aber jetzt machen wir trotzdem schluss vielen dank auch an rainer der wieder sehr kurzfristig und sehr zeit sensitiv kontext sensitiv intro eingespielt hat läuft also alles,
vielen dank an alle die zugehört haben wir sagen tschüss bis bald.
Wieder schauen wiederhören.